Yeah,
when I get get from a coma,
I'm going to switch to English since we
have.
Since Jordan hasn't had Dr.
Peterson hasn't had time to learn enough
icelandic.
Yeah.
Um,
so thank you all for coming.
This has been amazing.
Uh,
first when I got the idea to book into
Iceland,
I had no idea that others had been
watching him on youtube.
Um,
so as it turns out,
a lot of people have been and of course
he's exploded since then in popularity.
So we've sold out this venue which is
almost three times larger than the first
one we had and we've sold it out two
times,
so that's pretty good.
Thank you.
So,
um,
he's gonna come up here and he's going
to speak for one hour and 15 minutes
just about,
um,
then he's going to take a four minute
break and go off stage before the q and
a,
um,
you can submit questions to the q and a
and we're gonna use a similar system
that he's been using on his trips in
America with Dave Ruben.
So I'm going to serve as a surrogate.
Dave Rubin here are slightly less gay,
Dave Rubin.
So,
and I'll bring,
I'll,
I'll ask him the questions and you will
put them online on a site called slido.
So it's spelled l I dropped the O
slideshow,
I'll say it in Icelandic as well as a
punter,
dia or slidell.
Um,
so,
um,
it is customary to introduce the speaker
as if you know me better than him.
Um,
but,
and,
and usually when someone is being
introduced,
uh,
people tell things about him,
things that are true about that speaker.
Now of course you've all come here
because you know who that guy is.
Um,
but so,
and I'm going to do a different thing
because I think it has tells you more
deeply something about what is going on
with this guy.
So I'm going to read you a few things
that are wrong about him.
So these are actual things that have
been said about him in media,
mostly in hit pieces and um,
you know,
character assassination attempts and
there has been one each day just about
for a long time and some of them and be
big media.
So He's,
he's a bright guy,
Hitler,
he wants to force young women into
marriage.
He's the stupid people's smart person
that's actually not that bad about him,
but so,
and that's the reason they say that they
want you to become afraid to admit that
you like him or go to his talks,
well groomed,
alter,
right.
At least he's well groomed,
um,
a messiah come,
surrogate dad for gormless dimwits.
So that's another one directed that you,
um,
I,
I'm one of you as well because I don't
know what gormless means.
So,
but I,
I suspect that having a quorum is
preferable.
So just stay away from this guy them
with Jordan.
Peterson has nothing of value to say.
He's a patriarchal pseudo scientists.
He encourages young men to see
themselves as victims.
He's a Mashup of.
He has delivered a Mashup of cosmo tips.
And my first book of myths,
he's the professor of piffle.
Um,
he seems like a terrible therapist is a
bad political and social thinker,
an angry white guy.
And the line between Peterson's
authoritarianism and Richard Spencer's
Paleo Nazi-ism is a blurry one.
He's a Jewish shill.
And if you're going to be a shill,
you want to be a Jewish shoe,
um,
and he's a fascist.
Ms,
Mr.
This is just a small sample of what has
been going on and it's all wrong
perhaps,
you know,
depending on how you define chill,
chill,
she'll is okay,
but it's all wrong.
And that tells you something,
a new one everyday to miss informed
people about that man.
And you can demonstrate it.
It's demonstratively false everything.
And there are some people that see him
as a risk to their agenda and their
world view for some reason,
but he's a,
he's a reasonable,
a balanced,
moderate,
truthful man.
And I've never seen such a campaign
against any thinker ever in the world,
uh,
not even someone that is untruthful or
ask this despicable as they make him
sound like.
Um,
so this tells you something.
This is the reason I was reading this.
This tells you something about the
importance of his message.
And I'm not gonna I'm not gonna theorize
about exactly what that is,
because there are lots of theories about
exactly what it is in what he's saying
that is threatening.
And to whom it is threatening and I
think actually many of them are correct,
but let's just listen to him and let's
hear what he has to say and we'll,
we'll figure out why it's threatening
later.
So please give a warm welcome to Dr
Jordan b Peterson.
Thanks.
Well,
that's an introduction that I'm going to
have to live up to.
So I was thinking the other day about
numbers.
You know,
there are mathematicians who think that
there isn't anything more real than
numbers.
And that's an interesting proposition.
I mean it's obviously the case that once
you invent or discover numbers that that
confers on you a tremendous power and
who knows the limits of that power and
the claim that numbers are more real
than anything else is predicated in part
on the fact that when you discovered
them or invent them and start to utilize
them,
that your ability to operate in the
world expands immensely.
And,
and so that's one of the ways of judging
whether or not something is real is
whether or not when you use it
facilitates your means of operating in
the world.
Interestingly,
numbers are abstractions and so that
raises another question which is,
well,
what's more real,
the thing that's being abstracted from
or the abstractions and again,
that's not obvious and maybe the
question of more real isn't Germane.
Maybe it's a question of equal reality,
but it's not obvious that abstractions
aren't real and you can make a damn
strong case that there are more real
than anything else,
and so then you might ask yourself,
well then what are the most real
abstractions?
And so that's what I'm going to start to
talk about tonight.
I'm going to talk about it in
relationship to as many rules as I can
lay out simultaneously.
I'll go through the rules first.
So rule one is stand up straight with
your shoulders back,
and rule two is treat yourself like
you're someone responsible for helping a
number three,
which is very tightly associated with
number two.
There are sort of variations on a theme
is make friends with those people who
want the best for you.
And by the way,
these last two rules aren't injunctions
designed to make your life easier.
They're actually injunctions designed to
make your life more difficult.
Character Guard said at one point that
his role in life,
given that everything was proceeding to
become easier and easier in all possible
ways,
that there would come a time when people
would cry out for difficulty,
and so that's partly how he envisioned
his role in the world.
Interestingly enough,
as a universal benefactor of mankind who
would strive to do nothing other than to
make life more difficult for everyone.
Right?
And so rule two and three are like that
because treat yourself as if you're
someone responsible for helping isn't
the same as be nice to yourself.
It's not that and to associate with
people who want the best for you means
that they get to demand the best from
you,
and that's also not an easy thing.
Rule four is compare yourself to who you
were yesterday and not to who someone
else is today,
and that's an injunction about envy,
right?
It's easy to.
You need people who you need things that
are above you because you need to do
something worthwhile with your life.
You need something to a map,
but one of the consequences of that is
that you can become envious of people
that you believe have attained more in a
deserved or undeserved manner and that
can make you better and so it's much
better to compare yourself to yourself
and to use yourself as the target for
improvement and comparison.
Rule five is don't let your children do
anything that makes you dislike them and
the rule of thumb there is if you
dislike them,
then other people will and it's a bad
idea to allow your children to act in a
way that makes other children disliked
them or adults disliked them,
given that they're going to have to deal
with children and they're going to have
to deal with adults.
So your primary responsibility as a
parent is to help your child learn how
to behave so that the social world opens
up its arms to them and welcomes them at
every level and you've done your job.
If you can manage that,
and it's not a simple thing to do.
Rule six is put your house in perfect
order before you criticize the world,
and that's not take no action for others
until you have your act together that
isn't what the rule means.
It means that bind your ambition with
humility and work on what's right in
front of you that you will suffer for if
you get wrong,
before you engage in the large scale
transformation of other people.
Rule seven is do what is meaningful and
not what is expedient and I would say in
some sense in some sense,
that's the core ethos of the book.
Not exactly because rule eight,
which is tell the truth or at least
don't lie as a necessary conjunction to
that are unnecessary additional element
because I don't think that you can
pursue what is meaningful without
telling the truth.
And the reason for that is if you don't
tell the truth or let's say if you lie,
which is an easier way to think about
it.
You corrupt the mechanisms,
the instinctual mechanisms that that,
that manifest themselves as meaning and
then you can't trust them and that's a
very bad idea.
So the fundamental reason to not lie is
because you corrupt your own
perceptions.
If you lie,
and when you corrupt your own
perceptions,
then you can't rely on yourself.
And if you can't rely on yourself,
then well good luck to you because what
are you going to rely on in the absence
of your own judgment?
Your you've got nothing.
If you,
if you lose that rule,
rule eight a is,
as I said,
tell the truth or don't,
or at least don't lie.
Rule nine,
assume that the person that you're
listening to know something you don't
know.
That's not so much a mark of respect for
the person,
although it is that it's a mark of
recognition of your own unbearable
ignorance.
You know,
one of the things you have to do in life
is decide whether you're more.
You have to make friends more with.
Let me see.
Let me,
let me rephrase that properly.
You have to decide what's more
important,
what you know or what you don't know.
First of all,
there's a lot of what you don't know and
so if you make friends with that,
if you decide that's important,
then well that's a good thing because
you're going to be surrounded by what
you don't know your entire life and so
if you're appreciative of that,
then that's going to make things go
better for you.
But,
but the other element of that is,
well,
why should you be appreciative of what
you don't know?
An answer to that is,
well,
you shouldn't.
If you're life is absolutely perfect in
every way you have exactly what you need
and want.
You've put everything in order around
you then what you know is sufficient,
but if you believe that things could
still be put right around you in your
own personal life and with regard to the
effect that you have another people,
then obviously what you don't yet know,
it was more important than what you do
know and you should be paying attention
to find out what you don't know at every
possible moment.
And if you're fortunate,
when you have a conversation with
someone and you're actually interested
in what they say,
then even if they're not very good at
communicating,
even if they're awkward or even if they
display a certain amount of enmity
towards you,
there's always the possibility that they
might tell you something you don't know,
in which case you can walk away from the
conversation less ignorant and corrupt
than you were when you started the
conversation.
And if your life isn't everything that
you would like it to be,
than being slightly less ignorant and
corrupt is probably a good thing.
And so rule 10 is be precise in your
speech and that's.
That's an observation.
I would say that that's a variant of a
new testament injunction,
which is or maybe a description of the
nature of the world which is knock and
the door will open and ask and you will
receive,
which is a very strange theory,
let's say,
but which I would say is far more in
accordance with what we know about the
psychology of perception,
let's say,
than you might imagine.
Because it is the case that you don't
get.
What you don't aim at,
you might get what you do,
a mat and your aim might get better as
you aim as well,
which is something to consider
if you specify the nature of the
actually.
If you specify the nature of the being
that you want to bring into being,
then you radically increase the
probability that that's what will occur
and of course you all know that because
you regard yourself at least to some
degree as active creative agents,
right?
Your fundamental attitude towards
yourself at at least in the manner that
you act towards yourself is that you
wake up in the morning and you have a
landscape of possibilities that lay
themselves open to you and you make
choices between those possibilities and
determined in consequence how the world
is going to manifest itself.
So you confront a field of potential.
That's a good way of thinking about it
and through your choices you determine
which elements of that potential are
going to concretize them selves into the
real world and you are very unhappy with
yourself.
If you don't do that properly and you're
very unhappy with other people.
If they don't do that properly and
you're very unhappy with other people,
if they don't treat like that's what
you're like because part of what you
demand from people,
let's say in terms of sheer civility is
that they act towards you is if you're
the locus of voluntary choice in a world
of potential and you are braid each
other for that as well.
If you have children and parents,
your parents will say to you,
if you're fortunate,
you're not living up to your potential,
which is actually a compliment in a
sense,
even though it's also a judgment and the
compliment is I know perfectly well that
you could be more than you are and
you'll hang your head if you have any
sense and you'll think like you think in
relationship to your own conscience that
yes,
I have a lot of potential that I'm not
fully realizing and that actually
constitutes a transgression against the
good and I don't.
I don't think I've ever met anyone who
doesn't believe that.
If you.
If you have a reasonable conversation
with them,
it just seems self evident.
I mean,
maybe now and then you meet someone
who's narcissistically self satisfied,
but then they're narcissistic and that's
not good.
That as a,
as a medium to longterm strategy,
that's a catastrophe that ends in
disaster.
You know?
It's a short term.
It protects people,
but longterm it's.
It's not good in the least,
and of course other people don't
appreciate it as well.
Rule 11 is don't bother children when
they're skateboarding and that's
actually a discussion of courage,
of encouragement more more specifically
because I've.
I've been trying to understand,
for example,
what role parents play in the lives of
their children and I would say this is a
role that that that is a fundamental
importance as well as attempting to
guide your children so that they act in
a socially desirable manner so that the
world opens itself up to them.
You also want to encourage them,
which is not the same as sheltering
them.
It's not the same at all.
And to encourage someone is to say
something like,
or to act out something like,
look,
kid,
as you move the world is already
difficult because the world isn't easy
for children anymore than it's easy for
adults that the difficulties are.
They're not the same,
their child sized difficulties,
but there are still difficulties.
The world is a very hard place and it's
a bitter place in many ways and it's not
only a hard and bitter place.
It's also touched with betrayal and
malevolence and that's the fundamental
bottom line,
but there's something in you that is
capable of taking that full on and
transcending it and that's
encouragement.
You say,
well,
as difficult as things are Europe to the
challenge and to interfere with children
when they're skateboarding,
for example,
when they're doing,
let's say in advisably dangerous things
which kids of course do,
if they're skateboarding.
To interfere with that is to interfere
with the child's willingness to
voluntarily expose themselves to the
risks that they need to expose
themselves to in order to develop this
sort of competence that allows them to
thrive in a world they cannot be
sheltered from and so to interfere with
children when they're taking necessary
risks is not love or empathy,
but cowardice on the part of parents and
it's deeply damaging to children.
And I can tell you as a clinical
psychologist,
I've never had a client come to my
office and all the hundreds in,
in,
in all of the hundreds of encounters
I've had with people in my office.
I've never had a client say my parents
made me to independent.
Right.
That hasn't happened once.
Right now my parents made me too
dependent or I conspired with my parents
to perpetuate my dependence.
That happened all the time.
So there's a rule of thumb,
which I think is a good one,
which I believe is often applied in
nursing homes by people who work in
nursing homes,
which is of course a very difficult job.
And the rule is do not do anything for
anyone they can do for themselves.
And the reason for that is that it's a
form of theft,
right?
You don't.
First of all,
if you,
if you do something for someone and it
facilitates their movement forward,
then they moved forward because you
helped them.
Which is something I was very careful
about as a therapist.
I don't want to give my clients advice
first I it might fail,
in which case they are going to pay for
my advice and second,
if it succeeds,
then I get to be the successful one.
And I don't want to steal the success
from my clients.
That's a bad idea.
I want to help them figure out what it
is that they should aim at and then help
plot out a strategy for attaining that.
And,
but I,
I,
I want to ensure that it's their
destiny,
not something I'm imposing.
And of course the imposition of that
sort of thing is the hallmark of a bad,
I would say therapeutic relationship,
but also a bad relationship period.
Right?
So one of the things you want to do with
your partners,
your spouse,
your say,
your husband or wife and also with your
children is to listen to them so that
you can figure out what their problems
are and figure out with them because
they're going to figure that out by
communicating and then perhaps aid them
in the development of a strategy.
But you have to ensure very carefully
that you're not imposing your own
structure in a manner that's going to
steal from them what's rightfully
theirs.
So,
so rule 11 is an injunction to courage
as the fundamental,
because you could say,
well what's the antidote to the
catastrophe of life?
And one answer might be safety.
It's like,
well,
you know,
look,
everyone's sensible enough to
know that a certain amount of provision
for safety is,
is worthwhile.
You should probably wear your seat belts
when you're driving around in your car
because why take foolhardy risks?
But given that there is no security in
life in the final analysis,
then encouragement is a much better
medication than sheltering.
And so,
and that's what,
that's,
that's I think in keeping with the idea
that what life is essentially is not a
place to attain happiness or even to aim
for happiness even though you should be
grateful if someone comes along now and
then,
but a call to something like adventure,
and I think that's the proper way of
conceptualizing it.
Certainly if you go watch a story,
a movie,
you read a book,
something like that.
If you encounter a narrative that's
gripping,
whether it's a romance or a classic
adventure story,
then the element of it that's gripping
is the adventure.
And so to portray life as an adventure
in romance and and in the world is the
proper way to portray it.
And the way that you facilitate the
adventure is through encouragement.
I had a client once,
I really liked him.
He was a good guy,
smart guy,
good looking young guy,
had everything going for him.
You know,
he's a good musician.
He was a talented athlete,
but he hadn't been encouraged.
I wouldn't say he told me about his
relationship with his girlfriend.
He said,
no,
his girlfriend wanted to go biking
around southern Ontario.
She was about 19 or 20 and he thought he
might join her and when she went and
talked to her parents,
they made every provision possible to
help her prepare for the journey to make
sure her bike was in good shape,
to make sure she had the right equipment
to help her plot out a route and when he
went and talked to his parents,
all they did was worried that he was
going to get hurt and like he might get
hurt because people get hurt,
but they didn't understand that they
were choosing between the hurt that he
might encounter by going out in the
world and having an adventure,
let's say with his girlfriend or the
hurt that he would encounter by staying
at home,
powering in his basement under the
protection of his over loving parents.
Well,
his girlfriend ventured bravely into the
world.
You think,
well,
which of those two things is most likely
to be damaging?
And their answer to that is,
well,
his parents wouldn't worry as much as if
he.
If he was in the basement and that's the
wrong worry even because they should
worry more,
not less so in rural 12,
his pedicab when you encounter one on
the street and it's a oddly enough,
a meditation on fragility.
It's a discussion of what you do when
you don't know what do and that's really
when things have gone badly for you.
When you face a terrible tragedy in your
own personal life or in your familiar
life or perhaps even in the life of your
community.
When things come crowding in and you too
quickly in,
in the case of a death in the family or
a terrible illness or the collapse of a
dream or any of the things that can flip
your world.
Upside down is how do you cope with that
and that chapter contains discussion of
the necessity of narrowing your
timeframe.
You know,
because sometimes the right way to look
at the world is across years and
sometimes it's across months and when
things are more out of control,
perhaps it's across days and when things
are really.
When you're really up against the wall,
it's a car across hours or even minutes
and during those minutes than you
concentrate on doing as well as you can
with what's right in front of you for
the longest unit of time that you can
tolerate conceptualizing.
Maybe that's what you do at someone's
deathbed and while you're doing that in
suffering away madly,
then you also take the time to
appreciate everything you can.
That manifests itself.
That allows itself to be appreciated.
And so that's the metaphor of the cat,
I suppose.
And so that's the 12 rules and I'll
return to rule one which is stand up
straight with your shoulders back,
and I'm going to use it as a platform
for laying out the abstractions that I
talked to at the beginning of the
lecture.
So some of you might be familiar with
the central Dallas symbol and it's a
symbol of dao and dow is a very strange
word.
It doesn't have an easily translatable
single meaning.
At least in English.
It means a variety of things.
That means the path of life.
So that would mean the the path that you
take as you move forward through life,
but it would mean more also the proper
path.
So it's that it's the proper path
through life.
So the idea dow is a symbol of reality
and one of the things that means is the
path you take through life.
And so there's an implicit idea there
that the fundamental reality of life is
the path you take through life.
It's not a materialist idea,
it's a different kind of idea.
It's the idea that life is a journey
while we're mobile creatures and we're
on a journey and the best way to
conceptualize reality has as the place
that you journey through and the
question is,
well,
what are the elements?
What are the constituent elements of the
place that you journey through?
Because that's also part of Dow and the
Dallas believed that that's the Yin and
Yang,
and Yin is the black serpent because
those are two serpent's head to head
that make up the totality of the world,
and the black serpent is Yin and Yang.
Yin is feminine.
Classically speaking from the Taoist
perspective,
it's a symbolic representation.
It doesn't mean that women or men and
that men,
men aren't.
It's not that it's an attempt to use
sexual symbolism to a deeper underlying
reality and Yang is masculine.
Urine is dark and night and there's a
white.in
the block serpent and there's a black.in
the white serpent.
The serpent is the daytime and
masculinity and it's the interplay
between those two things that make up
reality and one can transform into the
other at any moment,
and so that's the Taoist idea of
reality.
And so there's Yin and Yang and they
make up the world.
And the question is perhaps that
question is,
well,
what exactly does that mean?
Well,
it actually means something.
It's a kind of abstraction and it's
actually an incredibly helpful
obstruction.
Once you understand the abstraction,
it might be the most real abstraction
there is.
So I'm going to lay out a little bit a
layout for you,
a little bit about what these two
domains refer to and then I'm going to
make a case that they're real and then
I'm going to tell you what it means that
they're real.
So you could think of Yin as chaos.
Now we need to know what chaos is now.
Chaos is what God made the world out of
at the beginning of time.
So one of the things that chaos is this,
it's something like potential.
And so you can imagine,
and this is not how we think as modern
people because we tend to think in a
materialist way,
but it is how we act.
And as I said already,
you act as if you confront potential and
you treat potential as if it's real.
And if your attitude towards it confers
on us certain moral obligation,
which is why you know what people mean
when they say you're not living up to
your potential.
No one ever says,
well what do you mean by potential?
Not unless they're being argumentative
because you already know and very few
people say,
well,
I'm fully living up to my potential.
So you admit to the reality that
undergirds that conception that makes
that question and possibility
immediately.
The potential is while potential is the
future,
that's part of it,
and we believe in the future.
We believe that it exists even though it
isn't here and it's not measurable.
It's it only exists as a potential set
of realizable possibilities.
That's what the future is and it's
really what we contend with.
We don't really contend with the present
precisely.
We Orient Ourselves towards the future
and the future comes at us from every
direction and we we,
we decide as we encounter the future,
which parts of it we're going to
interact with and how we're going to
construct the present and the past.
As a consequence of doing that.
And so part of chaos is potential and
that's the positive part.
It's like if you're in a bind,
what you look for is potential.
Is there another way of conceptualizing
this?
Do I have a different way of,
of
acting?
Can I make another plan?
Is there something that I'm not taking
into account that would make this
terrible situation tolerable?
That's all an attempt to to call upon
potential and to use it to transfigure a
reality that's intolerable and maybe
it's intolerable because of the way
you're conceptualizing it.
Now,
I'm not being naive about that.
I understand perfectly well that people
can find themselves so badly cornered in
life that they're basically done no
matter what they do.
People obviously developed fatal
illnesses and they die and their
businesses collapsed and genuinely
terrible things can happen to you that
aren't your fault,
that you can't fix.
I'm not saying that you can just
gerrymander the world by changing your
attitude.
It's not that straightforward,
but I am saying that you have a
tremendous ability to transform the
landscape of possibility that reveals
itself in front of you and that when
things are terrible,
that's your best bet.
It doesn't mean it will succeed.
It just means you don't have a better
option and so chaos.
That potential is also something that
manifests itself in a terrible manner.
So imagine this.
This is a good way of thinking about it.
So imagine that you have an intimate
relationship,
let's say a marriage and the marriage is
predicated on trust and fidelity,
which is a variant of trust and that
trust and fidelity is an axiom of your
memories.
You might think,
well,
what does that mean?
It's like,
well,
let's play it out.
Imagine you've been married for 10 years
and then your wife tells you that she
has had three affairs.
Each of them lasted three years and the
last one has lasted five years and it's
still ongoing.
Or maybe you discover that,
okay,
so then you might say,
well,
what happens then?
Well,
what happens is that everything you
thought was wrong.
Right?
And this is such an interesting thing
because it actually means you had the
past and you think the past is fixed.
It's done with.
That's why it's the past.
But all of a sudden you find out that
one of the things that you thought about
the past and it happens to be a very
important thing,
wasn't true at all.
And so what that means is that whole
past that you thought was what it was,
wasn't what it was at all,
and so it transforms itself from an
actuality into potential and most of
that potential is negative unless you're
relieved that your wife had an affair.
Well,
but that's an important consideration
because you know you can imagine a
situation where your marriage is
dreadfully unhappy and you're just
looking for an excuse to leave.
It's possible that that revelation,
even though it would be shocking,
would also come with a fair bit of
relief.
And so this potential,
the potential that manifests itself,
even when it's unexpected,
it doesn't only necessarily manifest
itself in a negative guys,
it can also free,
you know,
and if your marriage was unhappy,
even if you wanted to cling to it,
if your marriage wasn't happy and the
betrayal was revealed and you're
divorced and you set yourself up in two
years,
you might be in a better place than you
were.
It's not a pathway I'm recommending by
the way.
I'm just saying that it's more
complicated than it looks.
That's the introduction of chaos into
order.
Right?
And the,
the,
the oldest story we have is something
like order is susceptible to disruption
by chaos and the human,
that the fundamental demand that's made
on the human being is to contend with
the chaos that disrupts order not to
live in order and not to live in chaos,
but to be able to contend with the chaos
that disrupts order.
And so when you encourage your children,
for example,
what you're doing is encouraging them to
become the masters of the chaos that can
disrupt order rather than Denisons of
order which makes them tyrants or
denizens of chaos,
which makes them nihilistic and
hopeless.
So you train your children,
you encourage your children and yourself
and your partner if you have any sense
to be a master of emergent chaos and to
be able to contend with that.
And so,
so chaos has potential and it's this
disruptive.
It's the capacity of the infinite world
to disrupt your finite considerations.
That's another way of looking at it.
Another way of looking at it is it's the
serpent in the garden of Eden and the
reason that that story is set up the way
it is is because it's trying to
represent that there is no place that so
bounded and secure,
even if it's set up by God himself that
doesn't have an agent of chaos inside
it.
It's exactly the same idea that the
Dallas put forward with their,
with their symbolic representation.
It's just portrayed in a different
manner.
The question is,
well,
what you do in the garden,
given that there's a snake in it and the
answer to that is something like you
become the master of snakes and so and
that's a deep idea.
That's the same idea as confronting the
dragon in getting the treasure.
That's the same idea as going to the
bottom of the ocean and rescue your
father from the belly of the whale.
It's the same idea and that's an element
in the greatest of stories and the
greatest of stories is heroic,
heroic story and the heroic story is to
voluntarily confront the unknown when it
manifests itself and together something
of value.
As a consequence and to share it with
the community,
there isn't a story that's more
emblematic of what it means to be human
then that,
that that is us.
That's our best bet.
All right,
so chaos.
Chaos is the catastrophe that will
suddenly enter your life.
Chaos is the flood.
That's definitely coming.
Chaos is the ever present possibility of
apocalypse in your personal life and
your familiar life and in this broader
social life,
right?
Chaos is the consequence of your finite
fragility existing in a world that's
beyond you.
Chaos is potential.
Chaos is what lies before you.
Chaos is what you can call on when you
need something to rescue yourself from
malfunctioning order.
It's a permanent element of existence.
Chaos is what you don't know.
Chaos is what's outside the fire.
Chaos is what's outside the walls of
your house.
your town.
Chaos is what's outside of the borders
of your country.
All of that is chaos and potential
order
order is where you are when what you're
doing is working in the manner that you
intended.
Okay?
It's a very specific definition.
How do you know that you know what
you're doing?
Well,
you don't because you don't know what
you're doing because you don't know
everything.
Everything you do is bounded by
ignorance while you still have to
operate in the world and so what you do
is you make a finite plans and then you
execute plans and then you execute
strategies to make those plans manifest
themselves,
and if the plan's manifest themselves
the way that you desired,
then you regard your knowledge as
sufficient.
That's your definition of truth and it's
the only definition of truth that you
can use because you don't have
everything at hand and when you're aware
what you're doing is working that's
order and you might think,
well,
I should just stay there because that's
a comfortable place to be and there's a
certain amount of truth to that except
for one thing.
If you've
defined a domain of order and you stand
in it and you wait,
the disorder will enter all by itself
because things aren't static.
Things change all the time and your
attempt to bind yourself within a static
structure is destined to fail because
everything around you is in flux and the
thing that you parceled out as permanent
will transform itself across time.
Here's an example.
Let's say you're a perfectly well
adapted 11 year old and it's actually
possible to meet an 11 year old.
Children are often very delightful
because they're like adult children.
They're not teenagers.
They're like as they're.
They're the most mature form of children
and they can be really delightful people
and then like three years later you hate
them and and the reason for that is that
of course,
as soon as they hit puberty,
which is the emergence of chaos into
the,
into the already developed childhood
structure,
it's really the emergence of sexuality
into a structure that didn't have to
adapt to sexuality and maybe even the
emergence of aggression to some degree,
but mostly sexuality.
If the child maintains only the 11 year
old personality by the time they're 16,
they're no longer a delightful 11 year
old.
There are very immature 16 year old and
the reason that I'm pointing that out is
because just because something works for
you now doesn't mean it's going to work
for you five years from now and so in
order to remain stable,
you can't be stagnant.
They're not the same thing.
Stability is a dynamic,
not a not something static,
and so not only do you have to be where
you are,
but you have to be going to where you're
going and you have to be participating
in both of those things actively.
So it's stability plus transformation
and and I would say that manifests
itself.
You know when you're there because that
manifests itself as meaningful.
That's actually the.
The instinct of meaning,
which is an instinct and perhaps the
deepest instinct is precisely the
instinct that tells you when where you
are as sufficiently stable,
but you're transforming yourself at a
sufficient rate to keep up with
everything that's changing.
And you know that because if you're at
your job,
you might say to yourself,
well,
my job is really secure,
but it's not very challenging and you
think,
well why do you care about that?
It's very secure and answer to that is,
well,
if it's not challenging,
it's deadening in a sense,
right?
The spirit goes out of it.
If it's not challenging,
you need to be challenged.
And why is that?
Well,
the answer is well,
tomorrow is coming and whoever you are
now isn't enough for tomorrow.
And so today you also have to be
preparing for tomorrow and next week and
next year.
And if your job isn't challenging than
it isn't doing that for you,
and you find it deadening,
not meaningful.
And the reason for that is that it
violates your most essential instinct
and your most essential instinct is the
instinct for meaning.
And it signifies that.
It actually signifies that you have the
balance between chaos and order right
deeply,
right?
Which is why it's the most fundamental
of instincts because chaos in order are
the most real of things.
Alright?
So you have the chaos that surrounds
you.
And in some some sense,
infinite in scope,
and then you have the order that you
produce,
which is your mastery of it.
Well,
let's take order a part for a minute.
We want to think about the structure of
order and bill.
And I'm not saying that chaos is bad in
order is good.
I'm not saying that at all.
That's not the right way to look at it.
It's the balance.
It's the balance between them that's of
crucial importance.
They just,
they exist as superordinate categories.
Whether you liked them or not is really
not that relevant.
They're,
they're,
they're the fundamental constituent
elements of reality.
Um,
you might say,
well,
what's your evidence for that?
And I can tell you one piece of evidence
which I won't go into for for very much
time.
You have two hemispheres.
And each in your brain,
your brain is composed of two
hemispheres,
which implies something about the nature
of the world.
Given that your brain is hypothetically
adapted to the structure of the world.
It's not just your brain because animal
brains have the same fundamental
structure,
this bifurcated structure.
And the bifurcation indicates that
there's two fundamental realities
because otherwise why would you need a
bifurcated structure or maybe you needed
try you brain or one that's divided into
four,
but that isn't what you have.
You have one that's divided into two and
if your working definition of reality is
scientific,
biological,
let's say,
then your definition of reality is
reality is that which shapes life.
You can't actually do better than that
from a Darwinian perspective.
And if the reality that shaped life
produced a bifurcated representational
structure,
then that implies that the proper way to
represent reality and perhaps that
reality itself is in fact bifurcated.
And I believe it's bifurcated in the
manner I just described and the
neurological evidence for that is
actually quite overwhelming.
It's come from multiple sources,
some of them Russian,
some of them American.
That's where most of the work has been
done.
Your left hemisphere is specialized for
operation in those situations that you
know and understand,
and your right hemisphere is specialized
for operation in those situations that
you neither know nor understand.
And the proper way to Orient Yourself in
life is to get the balance between those
two sets of operations.
Correct.
And the way that manifests itself in
your subjective experiences as
meaningful engagement.
And so that's not a bad first pass.
What would you say?
Justification for the view that these
two domains are the most real domains.
Okay,
so order.
What is order?
Well,
if you just sit there and do nothing,
that will be chaos.
Why?
Well,
because you'll.
You'll suffer and die.
That's what will happen.
So without action on your part,
deterioration in death is a certainty.
Okay?
So you need to act.
While then we built on an action
platform being where the consequences of
3 billion years of evolution for action,
action,
movement forward in the face of
necessity is the prime dictum of life.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
Were embodied action.
What do you have to do when you act?
Well,
at minimum you have to do,
keeps you able to act.
These are truisms,
right?
I mean,
you have to have something to eat.
You have to have some fresh water.
You need some shelter,
right?
You need some companionship.
You need a sexual partner,
you need children.
You need play.
You need to be touched.
There's,
there's an.
I mean,
I actually mean need by the way.
People deprived of play go insane.
People who aren't touched,
die.
These things are necessary.
Well,
assuming that survival itself is
necessary,
but we'll start with that.
We'll start with the assumption that
just sitting there and suffering and
dying is not the right solution.
Okay,
so you have to act in the world.
You have to act in the world that in a
manner that stops you from deteriorating
and dying at minimum,
and that means that you have to address
the problems that are intrinsic to that
destiny.
Now you have all sorts of systems that
evolved,
have evolved to help you do that.
Motivational systems we have to eat so
you get hungry.
You have to find water and consume it so
you get thirsty,
you get lonely,
you get curious.
There's,
there's,
there's specialized biological systems
that are very,
very old.
You get aggressive,
you get afraid.
You suffer pain.
All those specialized systems for all of
those unit directional systems of
orientation in the world and they help
you figure out what to do so when you're
hungry,
it's time to eat and when you're thirsty
it's it's time to drink and when your
lonesome,
it's time to seek out some companionship
and you have specialized systems that
help you do that,
but they're not enough because,
well,
they're not very bright.
That's one way of looking at it.
They're kind of uni dimensional and you
also have the problem of organizing all
of them.
It's like,
well,
you have to eat now and you have to
drink now and you need a companion and
it's probably time to play and you have
to do something about shelter and there
isn't just you right now.
There's you now and tomorrow and next
week and a year from now and five years
from now.
So you have to plan across all those
stretches of time and there isn't just
you now in the future.
You,
there's you plus your family and your
community and so all of that has to be
taken into account while you're plotting
your movement forward is very,
very complicated.
You have all these problems to solve
simultaneously and your motivational
systems,
anger,
hunger and so forth can help you solve
one of those problems now,
but not all of them permanently.
That requires higher cognitive function
and that's part of what drove the
evolution of our complex cognitive
systems.
That's how do you propagate the game
across time in a complex environment,
the left hemisphere operates when,
where,
when what you're doing works and so a
lot of what you do during your life is
to keep your right hemisphere off.
People don't like it going on
accidentally.
It's the home of negative emotion.
It's the home of pain and anxiety.
It's the thing that turns on and freezes
you in your tracks when something that
you deeply did not expect happens and it
prepares you to deal with the onslaught
of what you didn't expect.
Now,
it's not all bad news because to use the
right hemisphere in a judicious manner
is also something that adds intrigue and
interest in artistic expression and all
sorts of positive things to your life,
so because potential is not only
negative,
it's also positive.
It can be,
it can be dealt with in ways that are
deeply enriching and meaningful order.
Okay,
so you have to do something.
Otherwise the consequences are dire.
To do something you have to value
something.
It's a definitional issue because to do
something is to act out the proposition
that the thing you're doing,
the thing you're aiming at,
let's say is preferable to the thing you
have and preferable means you'll do it
so those things are tied together so
tightly.
You can't disentangle them.
If you say,
I'm aiming at x,
but I don't value it,
then there's something wrong with the
way that you're conceptualizing the
statement because to aim at something
and to work to bring it into existence
is the same as valuing it.
And if you say,
well,
I don't value it,
then something's out of kilter.
Either you're acting out a falsehood or
you don't know what you're talking
about.
It's one of those two things and you
meet people like that are deeply
confused there.
Their action patterns and their verbal
self representation don't Mesh,
but that doesn't mean that they're
critics of value.
It just means that they're deeply
confused,
so you have to act or you suffer.
In order to act,
you have to have a value structure
because to act you have to value one
thing more than another,
which means that you have to inhabit a
structure of value.
You have to,
okay,
so you need a structure value because
it's the antidote to catastrophe.
Now,
if you act out a structure of values
socially,
which you will because you're social,
you're not going to pursue your aims in
isolation because you're not.
You're not a solitary animal.
You're a social animal,
you're a tribal animal.
Deeply tribal.
We live in groups.
We live in families,
we live in communities.
We live in large societies were social
at every level of analysis and we've
been social for as long as we've been
primates,
so maybe that's.
That's at least 6 million years and it
might be more like 60 million years.
It's really a long time,
so it's not an arbitrary social
construction.
It's far,
far deeper than that.
Now what happens when you act out a
structure of value in a social
environment,
you produce a hierarchy inevitably.
Well,
let's think it through.
Why?
Well,
let's say that you say that one thing is
more worth doing than another,
whatever it happens to me,
and then you tell a bunch of people
about what you're doing and they decide
that they're going to come along and
help you do this thing that's valuable
because they also think it's valuable
and maybe you get 20 people together to
do this thing.
Whatever it happens to me,
and the first thing you discover is that
some of the people are way better at
doing whatever it is that they're doing
than other people.
So and that.
And who knows why that is because it
depends on what you chose to do,
you know,
if you chose a then it would be a
different group of people who were good
at it.
Then if you chose B,
because people differ in their
abilities.
But one thing you will not escape from
if you make an organization to do
something valuable is the brute fact
that it will be a minority of the people
who are good at doing it.
And there's actually a law,
it's called price's law and it's a real
law.
Even governs the size of cities and the
massive stars in the heights of plants
in the jungle.
It just doesn't govern human
interactions.
And price's law says that the square
root of the number of people engaged in
an enterprise.
We'll do half the work.
So if you have 10 people doing
something,
three of them will do half the work.
But if you have 100 people doing
something,
then 10 of them will do half the work.
And if you have 10,000
people doing something than 100 of them
will do half the work.
And the.
You know how wealth distributes itself
such that a minority of people have most
of the money.
Twelve 85 richest people in the world
have as much money as the bottom two and
a half billion.
It's something like that.
And everybody goes,
oh my God,
the one percent.
It's like,
well,
first of all,
you're all the one percent,
so get over yourself because you're,
you know,
western European,
roughly speaking and by world current
world standards,
and certainly by historical standards,
you're all well ensconced in the one
percent.
So if that's a problem,
well it's a problem for all of you and
some of you might be,
you know,
richer than that,
but that doesn't mean all of you aren't
in the same boat.
Fundamentally,
the fact that wealth aggregates in the
hands of a small number of people is
part of the general expression of
price's law.
There's nothing special about the
distribution of money.
You see the same thing in every creative
domain mean how many of you have have
recorded a gold record?
How many looks like zero up?
There's one,
one person,
okay,
there's 850 people in here.
So there's one in a thousand.
So that's one 10th of one percent.
Something like that.
How many of you have written a piano
concerto?
How bout painted a painting that's
hanging in a national museum?
Oh look,
it's none of you again.
Right?
Well,
and how many of you have been a member
of a professional sports team?
Okay,
look up one one.
So that's one in a thousand.
Well you get the point here.
Well if there was a couple,
there was.
Okay.
So it looks like it's easier to be a
member of a professional sports team or
my or my audiences is biased.
The sample is biased but.
But it is the case.
If you look at high levels of creative
achievement,
of the sword I've just described,
they characterize it staggering minority
of people.
And so the rule is is that you produce a
value system which you better produce
because otherwise you suffer and die and
it isn't only that,
only that.
It's like,
look,
here's something else you all know.
As far as I can tell,
we start with the idea that there's an
intrinsic chaotic element to life and
that includes the inevitability of
suffering and malevolence betrayal at
the hands of yourself and other people,
so that's the baseline and that's
intolerable in many ways because life is
in many ways intolerable.
And the question is,
well,
what do you do in the face of something
that's intolerable?
And the answer is when you try to find
something that justifies it,
right,
you want to have something that gets you
the hell out of bed in the morning and
not just any old morning but a morning
when your father has Alzheimer's disease
and your daughter has an incurable
illness because you need something to
get out of bed for in those mornings
too,
and that better be the purpose that you
found in life.
And if the purpose is going to be such
that it gets you out of bed in the
mornings,
it better be a pretty damn noble purpose
because otherwise why would you bother?
And so not only do you need a value
structure,
you need one that's of sufficient
tension,
let's say,
or sufficient value or sufficient
nobility so that it's worth suffering
for because you're going to suffer and
you better have something that makes the
suffering justifiable,
and so not only do you need the value
structure so that you don't just
deteriorate and die.
You need the value structure so that
when the flood comes in your life as it
certainly will,
that you have built a vessel that will
sustain you through the catastrophe.
And that's not this pursuit of
happiness.
It's not even the pursuit of security.
It's none of that.
It's your the orientation that you've
managed to produce in your own life
towards our higher good that's so high
that it's worth bearing the burden of
being to produce.
You implement that in the world.
You produce a hierarchy.
Now you might say,
well,
and then you have the problem of
hierarchy and the problem of hierarchy
is a very few people are going to be
very good at whatever that hierarchy
does.
And then you have the second problem
with hierarchy,
which is the problem I just laid out
when I asked you about your spectacular
levels of attainment and found out that
they were very.
It was very unlikely.
I'm not saying that you haven't attained
worthwhile things.
That's not my point.
My point is,
is that very high levels of attainment
or rare and that's an inevitability.
As soon as you decide that something's
worth doing to inevitabilities people
stack up at the top minority of people
stack up at the top and take most of the
proceeds,
whatever they happen to be or deserve
them or earn them,
whatever,
however,
I don't care how you conceptualize it
and almost everybody else stacks up at
the bottom.
And so the problem with hierarchies is
that even though they're necessary,
they tend to produce a situation where
most people stack up at the bottom.
And so that's the next thing that we
have to contend with.
You can't get rid of the hierarchies
because if you get rid of the
hierarchies,
there's no value structure.
And if there's no value structure,
not only do you deteriorate and die,
you want to deteriorate and die,
and that's not a good solution.
But if you do generate a hierarchy,
then you have the problem of the
hierarchy.
And the problem of the hierarchy is that
it will dispossess most people now,
to the degree that the postmodernists
have something to say,
that's what they say is hierarchies,
dispossessed,
okay.
And then we can look at that clearly and
carefully,
and we can say that doesn't mean a,
that hierarchies themselves are corrupt
or that we can dispense with them.
But it also doesn't mean that we have no
moral obligation to the dispossessed.
And we say,
well,
how do we deal with that politically,
conceptually?
And the way we deal with that,
at least in part,
is to produce a political spectrum that
ranges from left to right.
The deals with hierarchy and the
problems that hierarchies caused.
So one of the things that you can
reliably assume about someone who's on
the right is that they will be
patriotically in favor of the current
hierarchy or even more abstractly,
they're in favor of the idea of
hierarchy itself and you say,
well,
more power to the people on the right
because you need hierarchies so they
should support them.
But then you have to take the people on
the left who say,
yeah,
but what about the people who are
dispossessed by the hierarchy?
And what you have to say to them is,
yeah,
we actually have to do something about
that,
and you think,
well how do we do something about that?
And the answer is we don't actually know
because there's no permanent solution to
the problem of dispossession by the
hierarchy.
We don't know how to fix it.
Say,
well,
we could flatten hierarchies.
It's not without disrupting the value
structure.
That's a price you don't want to pay.
Well,
we could take from the top and put it at
the bottom.
It's like,
yes,
hypothetically we could.
But it turns out that when you try that
in practice,
it's very,
very easy to rapidly go too far and then
what you end up with not is less
dispossessed.
You end up with no one who has anything,
and that's not a good solution to the
problem of scarcity,
right?
To make equally dead or equally
starving,
which is essentially what the communist
states did across the entirety of the
20th century is not the proper way to
address the problem of hierarchy.
Now it has to be addressed even if
you're on the right.
Because here's one thing that happens.
Hierarchies tend to Ossify,
you know,
because what happens is that the people
at the top,
maybe they got there by merit,
but it's easy for them to Gerrymander
the system so they can stay there
without merit.
Or perhaps their children can stay there
without merit or they can.
Or the hierarchy becomes corrupt so that
people who only use tyranny and power
can climate,
and so you don't have a hierarchy of
competence and value anymore.
You have a hierarchy of brute power,
which looks like a tyranny.
So there's all sorts of ways that
hierarchies can deteriorate and we have
to be awake to ensure that that doesn't
occur.
Also,
if the hierarchy gets so steep that
everybody stacks up at zero and no one
can climate,
which is basically the definition of a
malfunctioning tyranny than all the
people at the bottom rightly think,
well,
why don't we just destroyed the game
because we're already at zero,
so what the hell do we have to lose?
And so one of the things that you want
to do if you're a sensible conservative,
is make sure that the hierarchy
maintains its routing and competence,
that it's transparent and that it's
climate will because otherwise it will
ossify and steepen and then it will
destroy itself,
and if you're a conservative and you
value stability and the hierarchy,
then you don't want to set up a
situation where the most likely outcome
is that the hierarchy destroys itself.
So,
so we can be intelligent about this.
We could say,
look,
don't be thinking.
You can get rid of hierarchies they've
been around.
This is why I wrote chapter one.
I talked about lobsters.
The reason I talked about them is
because not only is the hierarchical
structure itself as a permanent feature
of existence,
at least a third of a billion years old,
which by the way means that you cannot
attribute it to capitalism,
the free market or the corrupt
patriarchal west,
unless you're willing to make the case
that all three of those elements
contributed to the existence of
dominance hierarchies among crustaceans,
which seems highly unlikely,
so an and this is actually something
that's,
that you could think about it as an idea
that's actually directed towards the
productive left.
If you want to help the dispossessed,
don't blame the existence of hierarchies
on capitalism because it's wrong.
It's wrong that the problem is way
deeper than that.
And here's something else that's very
interesting about capitalism.
A couple of things you might consider,
you know,
we have become spectacularly wealthy
since 18,
95,
right?
First in the West Icelands at classic.
I mean you guys are so much more wealthy
than you were 100 years ago that it's
absolutely impossible to believe.
And so that's first happened in the west
to exponential economic growth.
Starting in about 1895,
there's a long tail,
I mean,
people were improving before that,
but it really kicked in around 1895 and
first happened in the west and now it's
happening everywhere in the world.
I don't know if you know this,
but you know,
um,
the eon set a goal in 2000 to have the
level of absolute poverty in the world
by 2015,
which is the fastest rate of economic
growth ever recorded.
We attained it in 2012,
three years ahead of the most optimistic
projections.
Right?
And so people are being lifted out of
poverty at a rate that has never been
seen in the history of the world.
Hope to the power grids provided with
cell phones provided with free,
with access to fresh water provided with
access to medications that decrease
child mortality.
If you look at the statistics,
there are so many things getting better
so fast you cannot even believe it.
And that's,
and here's,
that's a consequences as far as,
as far as the data indicate of the
operation of the free market system,
which does produce inequality.
That's the thing,
but as far as I can tell,
the only system that has ever produced
wealth and as law or has every system
produces inequality,
but the only system we know of that
produces,
produces wealth and inequality is the
free market.
So here's a question for everyone left
and right.
How many units of inequality will you
tolerate to produce one unit of wealth?
And if the answer is zero,
then you've gone too far.
You're outside the appropriate political
debate.
That's the wrong answer.
And if you try to impose that all there
will be as mayhem because the price we
pay for wealth is inequality.
Now that doesn't mean that you can let
inequality run to its ultimate extreme
because then you run into the other
problem,
which is the monopoly problem.
You've all played monopoly.
I presume what happens in every monopoly
game,
if you lay it out,
everyone's stacks out at zero,
zero,
except one person.
Now if you play at 50 times,
you'll find that it's hardly ever the
same person because it's basically a
game of chance and there's a fair bit of
chance by the way,
operating in the distribution of money
in the world.
It's not all chance,
but there's a fair bit of chance.
But the logical conclusion to a
hierarchy that can play itself out
totally is that one person has
everything and everyone else has
nothing.
Obviously that's not a useful outcome.
So,
so you know,
and there are ways that we fix that in
our society.
We have progressive tax policies and you
can argue about their utility,
but that's one way of rectifying it
potentially.
Another way of rectifying is that we
don't have one game,
right?
In a pluralistic society,
we have many,
many games that people can play.
And so if you can't be a successful
lawyer,
then maybe you could be a successful
plumber and if you can't be a successful
plumber,
maybe you can run a small restaurant or
you know,
there's a diversity of games.
And so that's a good way of,
of allowing,
of increasing the robustness of the
system.
So that you don't get hierarchies that
are so steep that they collapsed in an
in it upon themselves.
And so those are sophisticated
approaches.
Perhaps there are other approaches to,
but it's an intractable problem.
It says in the New Testament,
it's one of the things you'd swear would
be edited out because it's such a harsh
statement.
The poor will be with us always.
Well,
what's that in reference to?
It's also in reference to the matthew
principle,
which is another new testament statement
and happens to be an economic axiom to
those who have everything more will be
given from those who have nothing.
Everything will be taken.
That's the structure of the world and
you can't lay it at the feet of the
West.
It's the structure of the world.
Now that means we have to contend with
it and it's not an easy thing to contend
with and part of the reason that we have
a continual political dialogue and that
we need to have a continual political
dialogue is to make sure that our
hierarchies exist and remain intact,
but don't become so steep and corrupt
that they destroy themselves and you
need a left and a right for that and if
and but that means the left half has to
admit that hierarchies are not only
necessary but valuable and the right has
to admit that despite their necessity
and value,
they tend to stack people up at the
bottom and that actually constitutes a
continual problem.
You see that in.
You see that in the old testament
because one of the things that happens
in the old testament is Israel struggles
up to state and empire status.
Six Times its struggles out of the
chaos,
up to empire status,
and then it gets corrupt.
It loses the way.
It isn't.
Balancing things between chaos and order
properly that the kings get arrogant is
so to the people and they forget their
relationship with God.
That's another way of thinking about it,
and then a profit comes up and says,
you aren't paying enough attention to
the widows and the orphans.
You better look out because that
displeases God and the Israelites who
are stiff necked and arrogant think
what's God going to do to us,
which is not a very wise way of
thinking,
and so they don't take the steps
necessary to rectify their deviation
from the proper path and they get
absolutely flattened and the
consequences of that last for
generations like seven generations,
and then they struggle their way up to
something approximating empire status
again,
and exactly the same thing happens.
They forget and they collapse and
there's six stories like that in the Old
Testament.
It's all documented by a man named
Northrop Frye who is a Canadian literary
critic who wrote a couple of books on
the Bible.
One called the great code and the other
called words with power,
which I,
I would highly recommend.
It's an analysis of the Bible
literature.
Brilliant.
For those of you who might be interested
in human thinking,
fries thinking is a nice adjunct.
So.
All right,
so.
So that's the nature of the world order
chaos and order,
and your goal is to keep those,
the relationship between those two
things optimized and you do that by
doing what's meaningful,
not what's expedient.
That's rule six and you ensure that you
have the world construed properly by
following rule number eight,
which is tell the truth,
or at least don't lie.
You don't want to pathologize the
instinct that orients you in the world
and you will pathologize it by engaging
in habitual deceit.
And the reason you do that is when you
practice something,
you build structures that specialize in
that and then they run automatically.
So if you're living a lie,
which is a very common thing for people
to do,
then you're building neurological
mechanisms that view the world through
that lie.
And once they're built,
they're you and good luck unbuilding
them.
It's very,
very difficult.
That's in part what happens to people
who are addicted by the way they build
mechanisms of search neurological
structures that are focused on the drug
and those systems are alive and all they
want is the drug and they're not.
It's not psychological.
Exactly.
It's psychophysiological don't build
structures of cognition predicated on
deception because you will pay for it,
and so if you're going to guide your
life with the orientation of the
instinct of meaning,
then you have to be very careful with
what you say and write and think because
every time you say or write or think
something,
you build a little neurological
structure that's specialized for that
and it participates in this parsing of
the world.
So all right,
chaos and order.
Then you can say the order orders a
hierarchy.
Okay,
so here's the next question.
Next two questions is order a hierarchy
and then a subsidiary question would be,
if order is a hierarchy,
what's what either what is at the top of
the hierarchy or what should be at the
top of the hierarchy instead of
hierarchies of structure.
Value.
So that's the question is what should be
of ultimate value.
Okay,
so now we're going to take that apart a
little bit.
The first thing I would say his order is
not an hierarchy.
Order is a set of hierarchies.
That's a different thing.
So I'll,
I'll tell you how to think about that.
I think so.
Now imagine you have a child and they're
playing soccer and uh,
your child is a pretty good soccer
player.
No,
I'll tell you a different story.
This actually happened.
So I'm going to tell you a story about
hockey and I'm since I'm Canadian.
What the hell?
I might as well tell you a story about
hockey.
My son played hockey.
He still plays hockey.
He's a pretty good hockey player and my
wife and I used to go watch him play
hockey.
There was an arena just down the street
from us and there was a nice
neighborhood league there.
And so they'd start the kids into teams
and then they let them play a few demo
games and if any team was getting
stomped flat or any other team was
winning too much,
then they'd rebel the team so that they
were approximately equal in skill.
So that was the sorting of the teams.
So um,
and then they,
then they were on their teams and then
they'd play 15 games during the regular
season.
They didn't have a little tournament.
See who won?
And it was really good.
It was good friendly league and so my
son's team was in,
I think it was the championship game,
if I remember correctly,
and there's one kid on his team who is
the best player on the team by quite a
margin,
you know,
he was very fast on his feet.
He could,
he could skate rings around.
A lot of the kids.
He was good at stick handling.
He was a good hockey player,
but he had some problems.
This kid,
one problem was he wouldn't pass the
puck.
Now you think,
well,
why the hell should you pass the puck if
you're the best hockey player?
Which is pretty much what he thought and
the answer is,
well,
you're part of a team,
right?
You want to be the best person on the
team,
fair enough and you want to win the
hockey game,
but you also want to what make your team
mates better players.
How's that?
Maybe you even want to meet the people
on other teams,
better players.
I knew now I know that's going a little
bit too far,
but you certainly want to make your
teammates better players and you might
think,
well,
why would you do that?
Because if there are better than maybe
you won't be the best while that's a
boneheaded way of looking at the world
because first of all,
if you amp up the competition around
you,
maybe that will motivate you to to be
even better and it's a hell of a way to
win by making everyone else lose.
That's not much of a victory.
And so if you have any sense,
you pass the damn puck.
Even if you're the better player,
especially you especially do that.
Let's say you've got a comfortable two
goal lead,
well then maybe you can risk taking the
time away from that specific game to
build up the confidence,
confidence and ability of your teammates
and then maybe everybody thinks that
you're a bit of a leader and they make
you team captain.
Not even so much because you're the best
hockey player,
but because.
Well,
because why?
That's the question.
Okay,
so we're watching the game and it's
pretty exciting and it's real close game
and it's like three to three and it's a
minute left and now their team zips down
the nights and scores are really
brilliant goal and so my son's team
loses except that they were in the
championship and it was a really good
game.
So you know whether or not they lost is
not all that obvious.
They lost that game.
But you know,
there's a broader context to take into
consideration.
Okay.
So this kid,
the star goes off the ice and he takes
his hockey stick and he smashes it onto
the cement and he's all angry because as
far as he was concerned,
he was robbed.
And maybe that's because of his useless
teammates who he didn't really spend any
time helping by the way.
And maybe it's because the referees were
unfair and who the hell knows why but it
wasn't fair and his idiot farther rushes
over to them and consoles him in on his
loss and supports him in his notion that
he was robbed.
And I thought you unspeakable son of a
bitch
because he was an arrogant narcissist
and it was way more important to him
that he had a son who was a star then
that he had a son who is a good person
and that's absolutely inexcusable.
He made the wrong choice.
He sacrificed his son's soul in part to
help them save face for a hockey game.
That's not acceptable.
Okay?
So here's what you tell your children.
It doesn't matter whether you win or
lose,
it matters how you play the game.
And so that's what the father should
have told the son and he should have
meant it.
And even better,
he should have known what it meant.
But who knows what that means because
you tell your children that and maybe
they're not so happy because they lost a
game and they look at you like you're an
alien.
And they think,
well,
what the hell do you mean by that?
Because obviously it matters whether you
win and it does matter whether you win.
So what is it that you mean when you say
that?
And your kid asks,
well,
what do you mean by that?
And you go,
well,
I don't know what it means,
but it's a good rule.
So what do you mean by that?
Here's what you mean,
and it relates to rule five,
which is don't make your.
Don't let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them because other
people will dislike them.
That and you don't want other people to
dislike your children unless you want
your children to inhabit a world where
everyone dislikes them and maybe you do
because you don't like your children and
maybe you don't like your children
because you let them behave in ways that
makes you not like them.
And so the way you take revenge is by
not correcting them so that other people
will punish them because you don't have
the courage to discipline them.
And if you think that people don't play
that game,
then you don't know much about people
because they play that game all the
time,
right?
So
it matters how you play the game.
It doesn't matter whether you win or
lose.
Let's take that apart.
Well,
so the first thing is,
and this goes back to the idea of the
hierarchy is order a hierarchy and the
answer is no,
it's a set of all hierarchies or you
could say it's the.
It's the set of all possible hierarchies
because you know in in a society at a
given time,
there's hierarchies that function,
but that transforms and then there's new
hierarchies that function,
the specifics of the hierarchies change,
but the fact of the hierarchies remains
and so you can imagine a hierarchy as a
metal structure that consists of a
multitude of possible hierarchies and
that's going to change as life
continues.
And so what you want for your children
is not to be the master of our
hierarchy.
You want for your children to be the
master of the set of all possible
hierarchies
because then no matter how things
change,
they're ready.
Say,
well,
how is it that you get ready for things
to change?
And the answer is play so that people
will invite you to play.
Right?
And there's a rule for,
for,
for children,
for raising children,
and it really,
it's a rule.
One of the things you can do with your
children,
this is something good for men because
men are more likely to do this than
women,
although women can do it too,
but men are more likely to do it.
It's really good for children to engage
in rough and tumble play,
play fighting.
First of all,
if you have children and you've played
with them physically,
you know that they absolutely love it.
They will
rough and tumble play with you until you
are completely exhausted and they're not
even vaguely ready to quit.
They have an inexhaustible hunger for it
and they like it.
They like to be pushed to the edge,
so I knew this when I was a new father,
partly because I read work by a man
named Jaak Panksepp,
who was a genius,
an affective neuroscientist,
one of the world's great
neuroscientists,
perhaps the world's greatest
neuroscientist,
although there's four or five people
that might compete with them.
He wrote a book called affective
neuroscience,
emotional neuroscience,
which is a work of real genius.
He discovered the place circuit in
mammals because there's a separate place
or could in mammals,
a specialized circuit and he did a lot
of work on rats and showing that in
order for a rat to become socialized
because rats are highly social,
they had to engage in iterative bouts of
rough and tumble play,
and here's a cool thing.
It's a ridiculously cool thing.
So and this has to do in some sense with
the postmodern critique of the
patriarchal tyranny.
So if you take two juvenile rats,
males,
and you imagine you give them an
opportunity to play,
so you throw two of them into a little
player arena and you let them wrestle.
Okay.
The next time that you bring them to the
same place,
you can measure how much work they'll do
to open the door to the arena.
How many times they'll push a button,
say to open the door or how hard,
how hard.
They'll pull a few tie a string spring
to their tail,
and so you can get an estimate of their
motivation because the more motivated
they are to play,
the harder they'll work.
And rats will work really hard to play.
So you know that they want to play.
I mean,
assuming that you're willing to accept
the fact that if you work for something,
you want it.
It's like an operational definition.
So rats will work to play.
Now if you let the rats out in the play
arena and one rat is 10 percent bigger
than the other,
then that rat will win.
You might say,
well,
what does winning mean?
Rats wrestle like people wrestle.
They even pin each other and they
manifest play behavior to begin with.
Like dogs playing in a park.
You know how a dog looks when it wants
to play,
sort of hunkers down a little bit.
Looks up at you like expectancy
expectedly kind of move back and forth,
which is like,
okay human,
I'm ready to play.
And if you have any sense and you know
how to play,
then you look at the dog and you sort of
go like this and the dog goes like this,
and you cuff the dog not too hard and
the dog bites you.
Not too hard.
And then you can play and you're both
happy with that.
And kids can do that with dogs because
kids understand dogs and dogs and kids
knew how to play.
If your dog can play,
then you should not own a dog because
you're not smart enough to own a dog.
So it's true.
And if you have a dog that can't play,
then don't have a kid.
Right?
It's true.
Stupid.
His dog I ever saw was owned by a
psychologist that was really
embarrassing.
So okay,
so you put the rat to rats together and
there's the 10 percent bigger route and
there's the 10 percent smaller rat and
the 10 percent bigger rat stomps the
small rat and pins him.
So he wins.
And so now you're a postmodernist doing
the experiment and you say powerful,
tyrannical rat dominates hierarchy.
Really?
That's what you conclude and of
experiment and you're.
And it looks correct because powerful,
dominant rat dominated and one,
it's like,
okay,
except for one thing,
rats live with rats.
They don't wander.
They're not psychopathic individuals.
Wandering from isolated community,
dissect a community.
They know all the other rats and that
means they have to keep playing with
them and the rules for playing with
someone 30 times are not the same as the
rules for playing with someone once.
So Pang sap had the rats play repeatedly
and what he observed was,
okay,
now the next time you put those rats
together,
the situation's a little different.
The little rat comes bouncing out and
does the playful dog thing too.
The big rat.
So now the rule is you're the little rat
you lost.
You have to be the creature that invites
to play.
That's now your status.
So you bounced around and you know,
the big rats all cool.
And he's smoking a cigarette and he
doesn't want to,
doesn't want to play,
but they'll flick it away at some point
and think,
all right,
what the hell you know?
And so then he gets in it and so nico
can stomp the little route again because
he's a bigger rat.
If the big Grad doesn't let the little
rat win 30 percent of the time across
repeated play boats,
then the little rat won't ask him to
play anymore.
You think,
well,
if you think about,
you don't think so,
what you don't think,
why did Jaak Panksepp waste his time
studying play in rats?
You Think,
oh my God,
that's an absolute miracle because it
shows you that there's an ethic of
fairplay that emerges as a consequence
of repeated bouts of play.
Even among rats.
It's so basic.
It isn't even human.
That ethic they effect of fair play is
deeper than human.
It's real and it's the ethic that
governs iterated interactions and it's
not just in rats that we've seen this.
So chimpanzees are pretty damn brutal.
They're way more brutal than you think,
and they're really,
really strong.
Maybe six times as strong as an adult
male.
Now there's the estimates vary,
but there are plenty strong enough to
tear you to bits and that happens now.
And then people have chimps for pets and
they become adults and it's like don't
miss with the chimp because it'll tear
you to pieces.
And so and chimps are brutal and this is
interesting because they're our closest
relatives and so Jane Goodall discovered
in the 19 seventies that rats or tribe
or chimps are tribal.
They live in tribal groups like we do,
and they have a territory that's the
known territory and there's a perimeter
that's the unknown,
that's chaos and other chimpanzees
inhabit the chaos.
Foreign Chimpanzees and the juvenile
chimps patrol the perimeters in groups
of four or five,
and if they buy us a foreign chimp or
two of them,
if they outnumber them because they
can't count,
but they have a sense of quantity.
If five chimps come across to foreign
chimps,
they will tear them to bits and I
actually mean that literally.
That's what they do.
And chimps also hunt.
They hunt,
call a bus monkeys and they weigh about
40 pounds and they're quite carnivorous
and they will eat them alive.
They're screaming.
So there isn't a lot of empathy
regulating chimp aggression,
which is something to think about when
you think about human beings because
it's not obvious what regulates our
aggression.
And you might think,
well,
it's your conscience.
And like,
yeah,
maybe it's your conscience and maybe
it's something else.
You read the book,
have you read the rape of Nanking for
example,
and you'll start wondering very,
very rapidly about whether people have
any conscience at all.
So that's a story of absolutely
atrocious Japanese behavior in China at,
at the beginning of World War II,
and it's a horrifying book.
So read it with caution,
but it's very instructive.
So anyways,
the chimps,
the chimps are very brutal creatures and
so you might think,
well let's look at a chimp hierarchy
because chimps have dominance
hierarchies and they're basically male
dominated,
although there are lots of powerful
female chimps say,
okay,
who becomes the dominant chimp?
And the answer might be,
and this would be the postmodern answer,
the most powerful tyrannical brutal
chimp rules because it's power that
moves you up the hierarchy.
It's like that happened sometimes among
chimps,
but you know,
what happens to tyron chimps,
they have an off day and to subordinate
chimps each three quarters,
the size gang up to make a one and a
half super chimp and then they tear him
to pieces.
Right?
So here's the rule,
if you're a chimp tyrants meet bloody
ends,
so how do you conduct yourself as a
chimp if you want to be at the top of
the hierarchy and have preferential
access to the things that being at the
top of the hierarchy would give you and
the answer is engage in mutually
reciprocal interactions with your peers.
The chimps that rise to the top that
stay there stable he and also have the
most stable functioning troops by the
way are the ones that have friends that
are long term and permanent and engage
in reciprocal interactions not only with
their friends but also with the females
and the infants and so even among
chimps,
patriarchal tyranny,
a is not the norm and B is not the
proper motive approaching the situation,
and so that speaks to a broader ethic.
The same kind of ethic that is spoken to
with regards to the rat studies have
play behavior and you can see this sort
of thing throughout the animal kingdom.
There's A.
There's a pattern of reciprocal
interaction that seems to stabilize
social animals that isn't predicated on
brute force.
Now maybe the simpler the animal,
the more it's predicated on brute force,
but we are by no means simple animals
and the idea that our hierarchies are
fundamentally tyrannical,
the patriarchy,
which is a word that nobody who thinks
carefully should ever use casually,
that term is predicated on the idea that
a,
that are hierarchies are tyrannical,
which they aren't,
although they can become that way and be
that the most reliable means to
attaining status within a hierarchy is
through the expression of power and both
of those things are wrong.
They are wrong,
and nonetheless,
that's the primary theory of the social
sciences and the humanities and enough
of that,
we've,
we have enough data to indicate that
none of that's sufficiently
sophisticated to constitute a reasonable
explanation of the world.
So we should dispense with it as fast as
possible.
All it's doing is dividing us into
tribes and it's not solving the problems
that it's hypothetically intended to
solve.
So.
Okay,
so now back to the question.
So
there isn't a hierarchy.
There's a set of hierarchies and it's
like the set of games.
So here's what you're telling your
child.
When you say it doesn't matter whether
you win or lose,
it matters how you play the game.
What you're telling them is life is not
a game.
It's not even a sequence of the same
games.
It's multiple sequences of different
games,
and if you want to be a successful
player in the set of multiple sequence
of different games,
then you have to adopt a higher order
ethic and you don't subordinate that
ethic to victory in any one game ever.
So you put the manner in which you play
above your victory in,
in each instance,
and the reason that that produces the
best possible outcome for you is that
you get invited to play the largest
number of games.
And so let's go back to rule five.
Don't let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them.
Okay?
So let's say you like your children.
Let's say you love your children and you
want the best for them.
You've detached yourself in a little bit
and you think,
well,
I'm not going to be around forever and
they're going to deal with a lot of
different people,
single people,
like individuals,
groups of people,
children and adults,
and what they have to be prepared for is
to interact with that set of people in
the best possible manner because and so
what do you want?
Well,
let's say your child's two,
and it's still pretty egocentric because
children shoot two year olds are quite
egocentric.
They can't share yet.
They don't really learn how to share in
any technical sense.
Tiller about three.
It's hard for them to learn to share
between two and four.
They learn to share and to play and the
way they learn is by at least in part,
by engaging in reciprocal interactions
with their parents.
Now,
what is it that it.
What is it?
That's your job when you're socializing
a child who's two to four,
you have to do it between the ages of
two and four by the way,
because if you don't manage it by the
time they're four,
then you might as well give up because
it isn't going to happen and the
literature on antisocial behavior in
children is crystal clear on this point.
If your child's antisocial ad for you
failed and there isn't anything that can
be done about it,
it's a dismal literature and believe me,
psychologists and sociologists and
anthropologists and criminologists have
tried for like six decades to figure out
how to remediate anti social in older
children and adolescents and they
haven't managed it so.
So between two and four is crucial.
You want to help your child become the
sort of person that other children want
to play with.
And the reason you want to do that is
because from four onward,
other children are the primary agents of
socialization.
And so if your children are accepted by
other children,
then they're on their way because other
children will socialize them.
Doesn't mean you're not important as a
parent,
but it means they find their peers who
are at the same developmental level as
them and they start to reciprocally
socialize one another and they do that
through play and so if you've prepared
your child to be a great play companion,
then you can just stand back and let it
happen and you have to be around when
something breaks down.
When the system doesn't work properly,
you have to be there as a resource,
but basically you can sort of push them
out onto the playground and say,
you know,
you know what to do.
Go play and play is of absolutely
crucial importance as documented by
people like John Piaget,
so you're trying to make your child
maximally attractive as a play partner,
and the ethic there is while the world
is made out of a sequence of hierarchies
that transform and so you want your
child to be the sort of person who's
invited to participate in whatever
hierarchy organizes itself and how and
what should a child be like to do that
while they have to be.
Be Reciprocal.
Take turns right.
You don't always get to pick the game.
You have to find out what other people
want to do.
They have to want to play too.
Like there's all these sophisticated
ethical rules that go around play and
you know,
if you're playing with some of you have
played with kids that aren't fun to play
with,
well what do they like?
If something doesn't go their way,
what happens?
They have an emotional outburst so they
revert to the behavior of ill prepared.
Two year old,
they have a temper tantrum.
They burst into tears,
they thrash around on the floor.
It's not fun because when you play,
if you don't lose some times that no one
else ever wins,
so who the hell's going to play with?
Someone like that,
a downtrodden victim,
that's all.
It's not.
No kid with any senses is going to put
up with that.
All they,
and this is exactly what kids are like,
if they find out that their potential
play partner is a whiny two year old,
even though therefore they just start
playing and they go find another kid.
That's exactly what happens,
and so if you want that for your kid,
then make sure that they're whiny and
bitter every time they lose.
A good way to do that is to never let
them lose at anything so they don't get
any practice.
Well,
I don't want my kid to lose.
It's like wrong.
You don't want to.
You don't want your kid to lose in an
unsophisticated manner.
That's not the same thing at all.
And if you think the way you accomplish
that is by never having your kid lose,
then well then,
well then we're back to the.
You shouldn't even own a dog problem.
All right,
so then you might take apart.
What does it mean to be a desirable play
partner?
Assuming you're going to play
reciprocal,
repeated games across all sorts of
different contexts.
Well,
there's a.
there's a whole ethic that emerges from
that.
See Nature back in the late 18 hundreds,
he was the first person to kind of
caught onto this sort of thing because
until then,
people tended to think of morality as
something that was invented rationally
and then imposed from the top down.
But nature being a very intelligent
observer noted that that wasn't really
the case.
There was a ethic already built into
human interactions that we all acted
out,
but that we didn't really understand
very well.
So here's a way to think about that.
So imagine you're watching a wolf pack
and wolves compete for dominance.
And so the way they do that is they
basically have a play fight about it.
Now it's this fairly serious play fight.
And so two wolves that are engaged in a
dominance dispute will sort of sand
sideways to each other.
You know how cats do that?
Do you ever watched two caps fight cats
stand sideways,
think,
well,
why does it cat stand sideways when it's
fighting?
It's because a sideways cat is a bigger
cat than a hand on cat.
So the cat's trying to intimidate the
other cats so it stand sideways and it
puffs itself up including its tail.
And the reason it does that is so that
it looks bigger because one cat isn't.
The cats don't want to fight.
They want to threaten until one cat
backs down.
And so they puff themselves up and they
make horrible noises and they face off
against each other,
but they don't want to fight because the
two cats that are fighting my damage
each other,
then a third cat comes in and like wins.
It's a stupid strategy.
So it's.
It is.
It's so.
Most animals don't like to fight because
they might damage to themselves.
And then another interloper.
We'll just,
when it's a stupid strategy and human
beings are quite a bit like that.
We do a lot of posturing and defensive
display,
an aggressive display and all that.
But we don't fight very often for the,
for the same reasons.
And it's only when those other
mechanisms breakdown that we actually
fight.
So
what happens in a wolf dispute is this,
the wolves square off and they amp up
the threats in the hope that one of the
wolves will back the hell down because
what'll happen is the wolf will chicken
out one of them and then when it does,
it rolls over and shows its neck.
Why?
Well,
because when wolves hunt,
they go for the neck.
Generally.
Like wolves are quite cruel creatures in
some sense,
and they'll actually eat moose standing
up,
but generally speaking,
if they can manage it,
they go through for the throat and
they'll bring the animal down.
And so what the wolf is basically saying
is,
well,
you scared me half to death.
I'm a useful.
I'm a useless moose.
You might as well tear up my neck.
And other wolf says,
yeah,
you're pretty detestable and you're kind
of like a moose,
but I might need you to hunt tomorrow so
I know I can tear out your neck but I
won't.
And then the defeated Wolf stands up and
he's not very happy and he's kind of a
low status wolf,
but at least he's still got his neck and
the victor wolf gets to be high status
wolf and he gets to go hunting with his
partner the next day.
And so you might think,
well,
wolves have a complex procedural
morality and morality is don't tear the
neck out of your,
out of the per of out of the creature
you defeat.
That's wrong.
And then you might say,
well,
that's the rule that will follow,
but that's wrong because wolves don't
follow rules because wolves don't have
rules because they don't have language
and they don't think not like us.
They act like they have rules.
They act so that if you watch them act,
you could label what they're doing with
the rule.
That's how we got our rules.
We acted out in ethic and then we
watched and then we coded it in stories.
That's what our religious stories are
there.
The consequence of us watching what it
is that we do when we act ethically and
then transforming that into a story and
everyone's intent on that story exists
absolutely intent on the story of good
versus evil,
let's say,
because that's the fundamental story.
And why do you want to watch that story?
Because you want to know how to be the
victor in the set of all possible games
and that's what that story's about and
that's what movies are about and that's
what books are about and that's what
religious narratives are about.
That's what everything that grips us at
a literary level is about,
and the reason that it grips this is
because that's what the world is made of
and that's what we need to know.
So then you might think,
so here's something to think about.
I'll give you a symbolic representation
of this.
Okay,
so there's this idea in Christianity,
and I'm not talking about this from a
religious perspective,
okay,
I'm talking about this from an
anthropological perspective or a
biological perspective or a that'll do
an anthropological or a bylaw or
psychological perspective.
So there's this idea in Christianity
that Christ is whatever Christ is the
king of kings.
Okay,
so I'm going to take that apart.
So imagine that you have a hierarchy,
whatever it is,
and there's someone at the top of it,
and so that person has the attributes
necessary to be at the top of that
hierarchy and maybe it's a hockey team
and you go home and you tell a story
about how the best hockey player on your
team played while they were being the
best hockey player.
It's a little hero narrative.
It's a little fragment of a hero
narrative and maybe it's hockey,
soccer,
plumbing,
law,
business,
art.
There's all these hierarchies and then
there's the thing that's at the top of
all of them and the thing that's all
that at the top of all of them has
something in common.
That's whatever it is that's in common
across all the things that are at the
top.
So imagine this.
Okay,
so you could think about this.
Imagine that you're a novelist and you
want to distill some characters and you
want the good evil character because
what the hell good is your book without
a good evil character and you want a
good,
good character because the same problem
applies.
You don't want it to just tell a story
about some guy's Day,
right?
You don't want to say,
well,
John woke up at six and then he smacked
his lips four times in blank 20 times
and then he swung his feet over across
the bed and walked into the bathroom.
Because who cares about any of that?
They don't need to know that because you
know how to move your mouth and cough
and walk to the bathroom.
It's not helpful.
You want a distillation.
You want the novelist who have watched a
bunch of people in abstract it out,
someone who's good in a way that's good
across a bunch of people and you want
him to have abstracted out someone who's
evil that's abstracted across a bunch of
evil characters,
so you see that in hamlet for example.
You see that Dostoevsky where the where
the characters are bigger than life and
you want them bigger than life because
you want it distilled so that you can
learn from it and what you're learning
is that ethic.
Okay,
so that imagine that you have 100
hierarchies,
just mundane hierarchies.
Then you take the people at the top of
all those hierarchies and say that you
group them into groups of 10.
Okay,
so you take 10 admirable people.
Then you say,
well,
we're going to average across them and
we're going to come out with the most ad
with a composite admirable person made.
Out of those 10,
you have 100 to begin with,
so let's say you have a thousand to
begin with.
You distill them to 100 admirable
people.
Then you take that hundred admirable
people in,
you distill them into 10.
Then you take those 10 admirable people
and you distilled them into one and what
that one is is what's admirable across
the entire set of admirable people.
That's a divine figure in a mythological
story.
That's what it is.
And so the Christian idea is Christ is
the king of kings and that's what it
means.
You go into a cathedral and the
cathedral is across by the way,
and the cross is the place where
suffering is accepted and the cross is a
dome over it.
Then that's the sky.
Okay?
So there's an idea in the cathedral and
the idea is that the place of the cross,
which is where suffering occurs,
is the center of the universe,
which is the Dome,
and then you look up at the Dome and you
see this figure staring down at you.
That's the king of kings and that's how
to behave in the world.
That's what that image represents and
you think,
well,
what does it mean?
Well,
here's a way of unpacking it and this is
associated with its associated with the
idea of how to behave across the set of
all possible hierarchies.
Well,
what should you do?
according to rule one,
you should stand up straight with your
shoulders back.
Okay?
Now the people who have been,
some of the people who've been
criticizing me say,
well,
because I point out that hierarchies
exist.
I'm justifying them.
It's like pointing out that something
exists is not the same as justifying it.
It's just pointing out that it exists
and pointing it out that it exists
without justifying.
It is certainly not saying that the way
to attain dominance in a hierarchy is
through power,
which is the other thing that I've been
criticized for,
which is not what I'm saying.
In fact,
I'm not saying that not.
I'm not even saying that a little bit.
It's exactly the opposite of what I'm
saying.
Say,
well,
if you stand up straight with your
shoulders back,
isn't that a powerful stance?
And the answer is,
well actually no.
A powerful stance is this,
right?
Well,
not really because I'm not very good at
it,
but if I knew what I was doing,
this would be it and I put myself
sideways so I'm not much of a target and
I'm ready for attack.
Okay,
that's not this stance.
This dance is different.
Right?
And that that isn't this stance either.
This is a defensive Crouch,
this is what happens if you're depressed
and anxious,
right?
This dance is,
I'm willing to take what the world
throws at me.
Right in.
That might be the trials and
tribulations that are associated with
the hierarchy because that's a tough
battle in and of itself,
but it also might be all the terrible
unknown things that are going to come
your way and what's the right attitude
is stand the hell up with some courage
and take it right voluntarily with
courage.
So it's actually a stance of maximal
vulnerability,
vulnerability adopted voluntarily.
That's what the crucifix represents.
Just so you know,
it represents the willingness to take on
the suffering of the world voluntarily,
the whole thing,
and that's associated with what's ever
at the top of the hierarchy.
So the idea is the best possible
strategy that you have to be successful
across the set of all possible
hierarchies is to maximally accept the
fact that your vote,
that you're vulnerable,
to accept that as the price of being.
And that's the essential message.
It's not only the message of
Christianity,
by the way you see this sort of idea
expressed in all sorts of religious
structures in the daoists to return to
them say,
well where should you be in the world?
The world is made out of the catastrophe
of chaos in the tyranny of order.
Where do you stand in that place?
And the answer is with one foot in chaos
and one foot in order.
That's the line down the middle.
That's the Tao.
That's the way.
That's the point of meaning.
It's the same place that's at the center
of a cathedral.
It's the same idea.
You stand there because you're secure
because you have tradition and the power
of your civilization behind you and you
have one foot in chaos because that's
not enough and never will be.
And the instinct that puts you there is
the instinct of meaning.
And you can use that as a guide,
and it's a deep neurological instinct.
It's not some EPA phenomena.
It's the most real thing there is as far
as I can tell and associated with that
is a certain attitude towards life,
which is to venture courageously out
into the unknown,
is to put yourself on the line,
right,
to heed the call of adventure,
to risk yourself voluntarily.
You have no choice anyways,
right?
Because you're in this all the way.
There is no out.
That isn't death.
The full catastrophe is at your feet.
You can't evade or escape that,
but what you can do is choose how it is
that you're going to confront it.
And so rule one is to stand up straight
with your shoulders back and to
manifest.
And this is the thing that's so amazing
about this,
I think,
and that what lands are kind of ultimate
reality to the idea of positioning
yourself properly.
You might say,
well,
let's presume that you're a very
pessimistic person or a very realistic
person,
and you say,
well,
what's the fundamental reality of life?
You say,
well,
it's suffering and malevolence like,
okay,
it's a hard argument to forestall,
but I don't think it's true.
It's true,
but it's not.
It's not the final truth.
The final truth is,
despite the fact that that's true,
the ability of the human spirit to
prevail is more powerful than death and
evil.
That's the truth,
and you know that you know that.
First of all,
you know that because you're ashamed
that you're not everything you could be.
You know that because the people that
you admire are people who manifest
courage in the diarist of straights and
you know that as well because when you
meet people like that and you're not
like that,
they shame you.
That speaks to your deepest possible
instinct.
You know what you could be and you know
too that you see people contend with
situations that are so difficult that
it's truly a miracle that they can
contend with them.
You know,
when I of people,
well,
I think the people who work in funeral
homes,
that's a good example.
That's hard,
right?
That's death and grief every day and
it's not something that you can avoid.
It's like it's right there.
It's as real as it can possibly be.
I'll tell you a story about that.
I had a client who was very afraid of
being alive and she wanted to sleep all
the time and she took sleeping pills and
all sorts of other things so that she
could evade the burden of being
conscious and she was a very good
dreamer and she she wasn't doing well in
university and she had a dream one night
that Gypsy told her that she was
actually lucid during her dreams by the
way,
and she could ask her dream characters
what they meant and they would tell her,
which was something I'd never seen
anyone else manage.
In any case,
she jumped up this gypsy that she met in
the forest and the Gypsy told her that
unless she learned to,
unless she could learn to work in a
slaughter house,
she'd never finished her degree.
And so she told me that story.
I don't know if you know this,
but the classic treatment for people who
are afraid of things is to expose them
to what they're afraid of.
Which is a good lesson.
If you have children because he wanted
expose your children to challenges
because that makes them stronger,
it has to be done voluntarily,
but if you have posttraumatic stress
disorder,
let's say you're the victim of a vicious
sexual assault by a stranger until years
later,
you have posttraumatic stress disorder.
The most effective treatment is to get
you to relive the experience in is much
vivid detail as you possibly can and
experience all the emotions that
occurred while it was happening,
and if the.
If you do that,
the more upset you get when you do that.
If you do it voluntarily,
the faster you get better and the longer
you stay better.
And so it's a general rule of thumb in
psychotherapy is if someone's avoiding
something,
find out what they're avoiding,
break it into manageable pieces and have
them voluntarily expose themselves to it
and they they will be cured.
And that's the dragon.
Fight in,
in clinical practice,
find what you most want to what you most
need will be found where you least want
to look right?
That's a hell of a statement.
So she told me this dream and I thought,
well,
I don't know how to arrange for you to
work in a slaughterhouse that doesn't
seem like a very.
She wouldn't eat meat by the way.
She wouldn't go into a butcher store.
I took her into a butcher store once and
she had a very catastrophic reaction.
She couldn't handle it anyways.
I said,
well,
we can arrange the slaughterhouse thing,
why don't you go away and for awhile and
come back in a week and see if you can
come up with an alternative.
So,
uh,
she came back and she said,
I want to see an embalming.
And I thought,
Oh God,
okay,
how the hell am I going to arrange that?
So I phoned a couple of funeral homes
and I said,
look,
I've got this person who's really afraid
of death and she had this dream and I
told them the story and they said,
no problem,
bring her in.
And so I wasn't looking forward to this
by the way.
Um,
so we went and she was very,
very nervous because she certainly
didn't think she could handle that.
And as I said already,
I wasn't exactly thrilled about it
either,
but in,
for a pound in,
for a penny in,
for a pound as they say.
So anyways,
we went to the funeral parlor and they
showed us around and we asked a bunch of
questions like,
how the hell did they cope with their
jobs because that's just a mystery to
me.
And they said,
well,
it was actually really useful for them
to guide people through the process of
grief and that their experience was that
that had given them a renewed
appreciation for life,
which is well that would account for why
they were able to do it because it seems
like a very hard job.
And so we went into this room and watch
this embalming and I was about eight
feet away from this small room.
It's a pretty gruesome operation as you
might imagine.
And uh,
my client was sitting beside me and I
was watching her and watching the
embalming as well.
And for the first while she was just
looking to the side,
which was,
I'm not here and I certainly can't
handle that.
And no bloody wonder.
Literally and so,
but then she would take the odd glance,
say she'd go like this and then look
away and then as the minutes ticked by,
but fairly rapidly,
she was spending more time watching and
less time looking away until she was
finally doing nothing but watching.
And then at some point she asked if she
could come in and,
and put her hand on the body.
And so they gave her a glove and she did
that and then she went and sat down and
she was quite quiet about all this and
quite quiet afterwards and well.
So what did she discover?
Well,
she didn't discover the death was,
wasn't horrible.
She didn't discover that and she didn't
discover the death wasn't terrifying
because it certainly was.
But what she did discover was that she
was a hell of a lot tougher than she
thought and,
and much quicker than she would have
believed.
And she went away thinking,
Huh,
look at that.
I did the thing I was most afraid of
doing.
And here I am.
Not only am I not more damaged than I
was,
I'm actually better than I was.
And so from then on,
she had a reference point,
right?
Which is an interesting thing.
I think this is why primordial people
initiate their,
especially their young men,
because it sort of happens automatically
with young women.
They exposed their young men to
something absolutely terrifying,
genuinely terrifying,
so that for the rest of their lives,
they know the difference between what's
actually terrifying and what's just sort
of normal catastrophe because you really
need to know that,
right?
Because you need to know that you can
prevail.
And one of the things she learned as a
consequence of that exposure was that
she could prevail despite the realities
of life.
Of course,
that's what you want to teach your
children mostly by example,
is that they can prevail despite the
realities of life.
Of course,
that also means that you have to have
admitted to what the realities of life
are.
But the thing that's so interesting
about that.
Here's another story.
So you know the story of King Arthur and
the holy grail.
The holy grail is the ultimate value
that it's a symbol of whatever the
ultimate value is.
And King Arthur assembles is nights
around the round table and it's a round
table because they're all equal,
despite the fact that they have a king,
they sit as equals at the round table
and they all decided to go off to seek
for the holy grail.
It's either the cup that Christ drank
out of at the last supper,
the cup that held his blood on the
cross.
It's one of those two things.
It doesn't really matter.
It's a symbol of what's redemptive.
That's what the holy grail is.
So it's a representation of the ultimate
value.
The question is where do you go to seek
out what's of ultimate value and answer
in the in the tail of of King Arthur and
the holy grail is that each night
entered the forest when they began their
search at the place that looks darkest
to them.
So that's the thing is that it's
necessary if you're going to stand up
straight with your shoulders back to
confront the darkness of the world,
head on,
to take responsibility for the tragedy
of existence and for for malevolence,
that's what it means.
That's the what the Christian injunction
to take the sins of the world onto
yourself means it means it's your bloody
problem,
and to confront Satan in the desert is
the same idea,
is that not only do you have to take on
the tragedy of the world as if it's your
responsibility,
but you have to contend with the spirit
of malevolence while you're doing so,
and it's in doing that,
that you find your destiny.
That's where you find the highest of
possible values,
and that's the call.
That's the call to the nobility of being
because you might think,
well,
what could possibly justify your life
more thoroughly?
What could make you the best player of
all possible games than to take the
tragedy of the world onto your
shoulders,
to fight with all your ability against
the malevolence in your own heart.
Thank you.
The first one I'll choose here.
Thank you for coming to speak with us.
What do you think of Iceland?
Well,
first of all,
thank you all for coming.
It's quite remarkable to see so many
people come out for such a serious
conversation.
It isn't exactly
what you'd expect.
So everyone has been ridiculously
hospitable to me and my family.
Um,
we've seen some beautiful things.
We were at the blue lagoon,
which was very impressive.
We went to the house today where
Gorbachev and Reagan met in 1986 and
that was very interesting.
I went and saw some rare manuscripts at
the university this morning,
a goon lager and his crew of people have
been very organized and you have a
beautiful little capital city that's
extraordinarily impressive and you've
produced this amazing venue and your
country is cruising along on all
cylinders and it's a hell of an
achievement.
So that's what I think.
I,
I think that almost all the time when I
come to a European country,
it's amazing how well it works.
I mean,
this is a harsh place,
you know,
it's,
you made a lot of what you have and it
looks to me like it's just getting
better and so it's peaceful and
productive and civilized and beautiful
and hospitable and good for you.
And thank you for inviting me.
This one.
The next one is regarding the hit pieces
on you.
Um,
when such an article is written,
what is your interpretation of the costs
or further what potential explanations
are there for this phenomenon?
Well,
I think there's,
you know,
we could start with what I might be
contributing to it now.
One thing I've had to learn,
I've had some interactions with public
exposure for probably 15 years because I
worked a little bit with a public
television station in Ontario before all
this blew up.
My producer who was someone who was very
much on my side.
So I worked for a public affairs show
first of all,
as a regular panelist and then as a
columnist for a couple of years,
my producer,
who's a level headed guy,
well versed in what worked well in panel
discussions,
told me to be very careful about
controlling my proclivity towards anger
because it doesn't play very well
publicly.
And so now I kept trying to learn the
doctrine of minimal necessary force.
I mean,
I that aggression is a good thing if
it's controlled.
I think it's a good antidote to fear.
I think it's one of the things that can
help you maintain your ground in the
face of resistance,
but it has to be applied very,
very judiciously and it isn't obvious
that I always do that as well as I might
and if you're going to deal with
difficult and dangerous and contentious
issues,
then you're going to get punished for
your failures.
And so I'm trying to learn too.
Okay.
Detach myself and to not,
not in a,
not in an I don't care way,
no,
but in a watchful way and to keep all of
that under control as much as possible
and to use minimal necessary force and
it's hard to learn to do that well.
And so to the degree that I don't do
that,
then I instigate more opposition than I
might.
Now.
I have hard time with that to some
degree because I do find some of what I
have been,
let's say opposing,
um,
what would you say I'm.
It makes me deeply.
It disturbs me deeply and makes me
unhappy and ashamed.
That's particularly the case when I see
what's happening at the universities.
I'm not impressed by what's happening in
the social sciences and the humanities.
I'm not impressed with the
postmodernists.
I'm not impressed with the Marxists and
I'm certainly not impressed with the
people or the theories that juxtapose
the two in this particularly
ideological brew that's been fermenting
say since the 19 sixties and so it's not
easy to maintain equanimity in the face
of that,
but it doesn't matter because it's still
necessary.
Do you think their ideology has
permeated all of media or because not
all of it?
Yeah,
I mean that's the other thing is that,
and this is why dealing now,
now we can turn to what the media might
bring to this.
Well,
ideological,
ideological pre commitments.
That's certainly the case and inability
to see anything other than in
politicized terms.
Like I don't view that what I'm doing as
fundamentally political action.
In fact,
I don't view the battle that's raging in
the ideational substructure over society
is fundamentally political.
I think it's deeper than political.
It's at least philosophical and it's
probably theological,
but the but the people who've been
pillaring me,
let's say who tend to be the postmodern,
neo Marxist types,
or at least leaning that direction
cannot conceptualize anything that isn't
political in their world.
There isn't anything that isn't
political.
One of the things that you might
consider,
for example,
is you know,
I've been perhaps represented as an as
an advocate of free speech,
and of course there's a lot of debate
about what free speech really is from
the radical leftist types and here's
something that you have to understand
from the collectivist perspective that
dominates the radical left.
There is no such thing as free speech.
It's not that they oppose it,
it's that it isn't a move in their game.
It doesn't exist.
So if you stand up and say,
I'm manifesting my opinion as an
individual,
then that's not a acceptable move
because you aren't an individual.
You're an Avatar of your dominant group
and whatever you otter,
regardless of why you think you're
honoring it or regardless of whether you
think it's your individual opinion is
nothing but a power move in your
dominance hierarchy and so it's not like
they oppose free speech.
It's that it doesn't exist in their
conceptual framework and so that's one
of the things that drives and they hit
pieces because I do believe in the
individual and I do believe in free
speech and I do believe in a world
outside the conceptual realm,
all sorts of propositions that aren't
part and parcel of the postmodernist
slash neo Marxist game and they're not
very happy with that.
It's.
I'm not playing by the rules and so they
don't know what to do about that.
The simplest thing to do is to call me
far right,
are all right because then they can.
First of all,
that's an evil category and that
dispenses with that,
but it also means they don't have to
contend with any of my arguments and
that's convenient,
so it's easier to demonize than it is to
contend.
So it doesn't seem to help them because
the more they scream,
the more people that actually listened
to you here,
that you're not far right,
you're not all thrive.
And they stopped believing them.
Well,
that's the other thing.
I've talked with my wife about this
because it's been in Vr.
It's produced a lot of tension in our
family because it's very stressful.
I mean for all sorts of reasons,
but that's certainly one of them,
you know,
I mean,
it's certainly not the case that when I
read a headpiece that I'm very pleased
about it and I'm often quite worried
about it.
Like the New York Times piece,
for example,
is a good example and it's idiot.
What would you call it?
Um,
insistence that I was promoting,
you know,
monogamy with the weapons of the state
of all the insane ideas.
I mean,
who the hell believes that it's like
some isis guys.
That's about it.
So it's a completely absurd accusation
and it certainly bore no resemblance to
anything that I meant.
But you know,
it's a powerful media organization and
lots of people warned me in the
immediate aftermath of that.
It would be my downfall and including
people who were less,
they weren't fearful people and so it's
very stressful.
So one question is,
well,
should I be doing interviews like that
at all?
Because one of the things I've thought
is no written interviews only live
interviews,
only the whole thing.
So the one today you had the last one.
Well see,
I don't know because there's another
side of it which is the side you laid
out.
It's like this happened with the.
Some of you have seen the channel for
interview that I did with Kathy Newman
and thank you.
You know when that was,
I would say that was a stressful
interview and I would say that the two
weeks after the interview we're also
very stressful because,
you know,
first of all there was the interview and
I thought they'd just cut it to seven
minutes and pillory me and leave it at
that,
but they cut it to seven minutes and
pilloried me and then they posted the
whole interview,
which just shocked me.
But here's the shocking thing.
The people who posted that interview
thought it went well.
That's why they posted it.
They didn't think,
oh my God,
this is contentious.
We better put it out,
believe me.
They didn't think that that is not what
they thought.
They thought it went fine and so then
there was this overwhelming response to
it and that was completely unexpected
and then the counter response was
Peterson's army of alt right trolls is
victimizing Kathy Newman,
and that was.
That was the response of her employers,
the technical response,
because that's what they publish.
They said we had to call him police to
evaluate the threat.
It's like,
well,
so what anybody can call in police to
evaluate a threat.
It doesn't mean that the threat
justified police intervention or that
there was a threat.
It just meant that that's how you
responded to it and then they spun a
victim narrative for Kathy,
which was I think reprehensible.
Given that.
I don't know what Kathy Newman is
exactly,
but she's not a bloody victim.
She's not powerless.
She's one of the most powerful women in
the United Kingdom and she has a salary
that's commensurate with that and good,
good for her.
That's absolutely fine,
but you don't get to have that and also
be a victim.
It's not the right way to play the game.
And so then a whole bunch of newspapers
laid out the story that poor Kathy was
being trolled by my,
my legion of all right,
angry people,
but then the numbers started to mount,
you know,
and after it was like 4 million people,
it got the whole troll argument got hard
to sustain unless you think there are
like,
well now it's perhaps 30 million people
have watched either the whole thing or
major clips from it.
Maybe it's more than that.
It's hard to sustain the old troll
argument when it's 30 million people,
but it was very.
I thought that narrative was going to
prevail for a while that you know,
oh,
she got victimized and it was all these
terrible people that went after her.
But that collapsed.
But it's very stressful.
But,
and this is something that I've,
I've learned.
So I've been obsessing about another
statement in the New Testament for about
two years.
I've been trying to figure it out and
it's.
It's the statement that you should turn
the other cheek and that's a tough one,
man,
because.
Well,
because first of all,
who wants to do that?
Because you want to explode in righteous
anger.
At least you want to defend yourself.
You want to do one of those things,
so what the hell does that mean?
And partly what it means is if you're
attacked and you're innocent and and
look,
I'm not saying I'm like globally
innocent or anything like that,
but I'm not guilty of the accusations
that are levied at me or at least I not
guilty in the manner that the
accusations would indicate.
If you're being attacked and you're not
guilty of the accusations,
then the attacks
say more about the attacker then their
intended target.
And so so far I've been able to
withstand the attacks and the
consequence of that is that it said more
about the attackers then about meat and
then the question is can I tolerate
that?
Because it's still very stressful and I
vary our waiver on that back and forth.
And then of course,
the other issue is is that some people
in the media have pilloried me,
but many haven't been very many
thoughtful people that have written
thoughtful pieces about me.
There's a Canadian consortium of 200
newspapers,
the post media group,
and they came out.
The entire group came out in favor of my
stance in relationship to build
[inaudible] in Canada,
which was a speech,
a speech piece of legislation that
compelled speech and so
well.
So,
so far in same with the protests.
When people come out to protest against
me.
The first video that really went viral
was a protest at the University of
Toronto and after the protest was over
the the pro,
the,
the anti free speech,
people at the protests took the
microphone away in and blasted white
noise.
Made it impossible for anyone to speak
even though it was an open mic event.
So that got broadcast and then about two
after the event,
I went down to talk to the cops to see
if anybody had been hurt or anything
like that.
And then on the way back into the
university,
I got a cost by half a dozen,
like radical types and about 30 of their
hangers on and then there was a crowd of
people that I would say we're probably
supporting me,
that that gathered around me and they
went after me and videotaped all of it
on their cell phones and then they
posted that and the idea was that that
was going to do me in.
But what happened was the comments were
100 to one in favor of what I was
saying.
So that was another example where the
protests were more damaging to the
protestors then they were to me.
And that's been luckily fortunately,
miraculously all of that,
a recurrent pattern.
And so the question is whether or not I
can tolerate it and whether my family
can tolerate it.
And so far,
look,
if you're trying to do something
difficult,
let's say the right amount of
controversy isn't zero.
The question is how much controversy can
you handle and how much of the mud
that's thrown will stick.
And then how much of it deserves to
stick.
All of those things,
you've got to scour your conscience
under those circumstances,
but
so far I've been fortunate.
It seems like you've taken on this
dragon voluntarily.
It seems like from the beginning you
have known that this,
for example,
when you spoke up against the
[inaudible] in Canada,
you knew that this might become tough.
Well Guide taught people to negotiate in
my clinical practice for a long time.
You know,
I've had lots of clients,
many of those clients were female and
the are.
The goal in my consulting with them was
to double or triple their salary within
five years and so that wasn't
necessarily the only goal.
We discussed all sorts of goals,
but that was often one and so I was very
accustomed to organizing people to
negotiate and there's,
if you want to negotiate,
there's a couple of rules.
The first rule is you have to be able to
say no,
and what no means is there isn't
anything you can do to me to get me to
do that.
That's what no means.
No like you can be.
You can have different degrees of
seriousness about no,
but if you're going to negotiate with
your boss,
say for a substantial raise,
no means if I don't get it,
then I will leave.
That's fundamentally and leaving will
cost you more than.
It's not a threat,
right?
It has to be the observation that me
leaving will cost you substantially more
than giving me the race.
You have to be in a position to make
that case or you don't win the
negotiation.
And so I always put my clients in a
where if they went and asked for
something,
they were in a position to win because
we didn't go and ask before that.
So when I made the video criticizing
bill c 16,
I thought I'm not abiding by this damn
piece of legislation.
And then I thought,
well,
what does it mean that I'm not?
And I thought,
well,
I had multiple sources of income so I
was re.
I was reasonably position to tolerate a
fair bit of push back.
I mean I could've got wiped out.
He had things gone sideways,
but it would have been difficult to take
me out completely.
And I thought,
there's no way I'm abiding by this piece
of legislation.
I was willing,
I thought through the negative
consequences.
Now I didn't of course think that any of
this would happen because this is just
completely preposterous and no one could
have possibly foreseen it.
But.
So I would say there were certain things
I faced in doing that,
but I couldn't have foreseen the
absolutely explosive consequences.
I'm not unhappy that I did it.
I would do it again.
I am still doing it.
I suppose.
So which of your 12 rules to break?
Most of?
Hmm.
I could probably still be better at
listening to people I like.
I have these.
I do interviews with people.
I call them discussions because they're
not really interviews.
Probably they're not interviews because
I talked too much,
so I had to call them discussions.
But I would say the most common
criticism of those discussions is that
I've,
I interrupt the people that I'm
discussing things with and until the
conversation probably a little bit more
towards me,
my thinking than there is now.
Part of that I think is my natural
tendency towards like I've always talked
a lot ever since I was like three,
like continually.
So it's,
I'm there,
I'm verbally fluent,
you know,
it's,
it's part of my nature and extroverted,
but
you can always get better at listening,
you know,
and so I can listen and I practiced that
because I'm a therapist.
But I would say that's probably the
rule.
I break that rule nine,
like assume that the person you're
listening to know something you don't.
It's like I'm not as good at that yet as
I could be because I wouldn't get that
criticism if I was like,
it's not every comment or anything.
It's probably like every 20th comment or
every 30th comment,
but it's.
But it's still,
it's consistent.
And so every time I have an interview I
think,
okay,
I'm going to try to shut up a little bit
more,
but then I get excited about what's
happening and you know,
talk too much.
One thing related to that,
sometimes you seem to go off on a
tangent.
When you're discussing something,
you'd go into a,
a,
you know,
something related to it,
then you come back to a greater
structure of things.
Um,
do you,
have you laid all this out before you
say it or do you just go from one topic
to another and they somehow relate
together and become whole and both.
Both.
Yeah,
but so before I do a talk,
like I have to,
I think about the talk all day before I
do it,
like not 100 percent of the time,
but it's,
it's in my mind all the time.
And what I'm trying to get is the basic
narrative and it's something like you
can only use a metaphor to really
describe it.
So imagine you wanted to cross a swamp
and there were stones under the surface.
You need to know where the stones are to
get from one side of the swamp to the
other.
And so then that's what I do in my
imagination I think,
okay,
well there's this area I have to
traverse and there's stepping stones
along the way.
I need to know where they're located.
And so that might be like 12 points or
something like that.
That's the rough path.
And then I have a whole corpus of
stories that fit each of those points
and then I can choose how I'm going to
weave those together.
But I have to remember where I'm going
and if I'm.
Well,
like if I'm healthy and functioning
property then I can go way out on a
tangent and I can still remember,
Oh yes,
I have to tie that back to this point
and move to the next step.
So it's,
I like,
I think it's like jazz improvisation
essentially,
you know,
you have the melody and it has to
organize the melody has to organize all
the improvisation.
And then I have all these stories that I
know,
but I,
every time I tell this story I try to
vary it so that it brings in something I
haven't brought in before.
Integrate something,
you know,
like what are the things I was trying to
do tonight?
I've been trying to figure out for a
long time is how to integrate the idea
of the good player of games with the
idea of voluntarily shouldering you're
the catastrophe of life.
I know those are the same thing,
but it's not obvious why,
and I'm still not completely obvious to
me,
but I know that the connection exists
and I got a fair bit of fairways tonight
farther than I had it stacking those
concepts on top of each other.
So the other thing I'm always trying to
do is to take each of these sets of
ideas and to weave them together more
tightly,
but also to push them further in their
development.
So,
and you've been doing that on this tour.
Have you been developing your ideas?
Go.
Absolutely,
absolutely.
There's.
You can't give an effective lecture
without,
so you don't deliver a talk to an
audience.
First of all,
it's not at talk second,
you don't deliver it.
Third,
it doesn't.
An audience like all of that's wrong.
You talk to individuals in the audience
one at a time and they're representative
of the whole,
but you're not talking to the audience.
If you're afraid of public speaking,
it's because you're talking to the
audience.
It's like,
forget about that.
You just talked to people.
You know how to do that,
and then you're not delivering a talk
because then it's a canned product.
He muscled just hand people pieces of
paper that they could read.
It's more efficient.
Why not do that?
What you're doing if you address people
properly,
is that you involve them in the process
of furthering exploration of important
concepts and you think,
well,
how can you do that?
Because they're sitting there passively.
It's like,
well,
you're not passive.
You're not verbal,
but you're not passive.
Like I listened,
I listened to whether or not everyone's
rustling around.
If you're rustling around,
then I'm not balancing chaos in order to
properly.
You're not gripped.
If you're.
If I can hear noise in the audience,
it's not right.
I watched people one by one and I see
sometimes they're shaking their head
like this.
Sometimes they're nodding.
Sometimes they look confused.
If if people look confused,
I think,
well,
I haven't got that right.
I have to be watching people and seeing
that they're understanding,
they're following along and that
indication that they're following along
helps me figure out if I'm in the right
place,
and so there's a dynamic that goes along
with it and so all of that,
and that's what you're doing if you
engage the audience properly,
is you shouldn't be talking about things
you don't know enough about to talk
about.
So if you have to read your notes,
it's like,
sorry,
you don't know enough to talk about that
because you need notes.
Now.
Maybe when you're first starting to talk
about something,
you need notes,
but if you need notes,
you haven't prepared enough.
You should know like 10 times as much
about the topic.
Then you're going to talk about in the
talk.
Otherwise,
who the hell are you?
And so while right,
I mean you're.
You're supposed to be the authority so
you need to know these things and so and
then knowing these things,
you want to stretch them further because
when you're.
This is a theater in a lecture.
Theater.
Theater is drama,
so why is it a lecture?
Theater?
[inaudible] lecture is drama.
What's the drama?
Drama delivering a talk.
No,
there's no drama in that.
A tape recorder can do that.
The drama is to engage with the ideas
actively in real time and to discover
with the audience what the consequences
and that's what makes a novel great.
For example,
the reason that Dostoyevsky is great is
because Dostoevsky did not know where he
was going when he started.
He had problems,
you know,
like crime and punishment is a great
example.
He went to explore the relationship
between crime and punishment.
He didn't think,
well,
I'm a postmodern,
neo Marxist,
and I have a solution to the problem of
crime and punishment and I'm going to
write a novel describing what the right
solution is.
He thought,
here's a problem,
man.
This is a major problem.
I'm going to divide myself into 10
characters and I'm going to have a war
and I'm going to see what prevails and
he takes you along on that voyage and
it's what makes Dostoevsky different
than Ayn rand,
for example,
because Ayn rand already knew who the
good guys and the bad guys were and
maybe she was right and maybe she
wasn't.
Doesn't matter.
What matters is that what she did wasn't
literature.
It was just sophisticated propaganda,
you know,
like it.
It taps into literature upon occasion,
but,
but she knew where she was going.
Whereas Dusky Dostoevsky,
he discovered it along the way and so he
takes you along on the journey and
that's any great artists does that takes
you along in the journey.
That's why it's so rare vivifying to
encounter anything that's genuinely
artistic is because you're along for the
conflict between chaos and order and
that's way more interesting than having
a talk delivered to you.
Is it possible that that journey might
lead to a bad place?
In some cases you've spoken of Hitler
when he was speaking to audiences and he
was listening to the audiences and that
and he started to find what really
engaged them and made them.
Yeah,
excited.
He was saying,
is it possible that you might get it
wrong?
Oh definitely,
and it's a terrible threat to get it
wrong because you know,
in rule three,
make friends with the people who want
the best for you.
There are other rules that were
associated with that that I didn't write
about.
Like make friends with people with own.
No.
Let's see.
Be Very careful with who.
Be Very careful about who you share good
news with.
That was one rule and another rule was
be very careful about whom you share bad
news with and those are sort of
hallmarks of friendship.
If you have friends,
you can tell good news too.
You know what it's like to tell good
news to someone that you shouldn't tell.
Good news too.
It's like they're not happy about your
good news.
There are bitter about it and then
they'll show it in some way.
Maybe they'll trump your good news or
they won't listen,
or they'll bring up another topic or
they're secretly angry or whatever.
You walk away from sharing the good news
thinking you should have kept your damn
mouth shut and that's not a good sign.
And then.
But some people you can tell a good news
too and they'll be happy because they
have enough sense to know that life's to
catastrophe and if something good
happened to you,
then hooray.
You know,
because and then bad news is the same
thing.
It's like if you tell news to someone
they need to let you suffer,
right?
They shouldn't make you feel better
quick because they're upset because
you're upset.
None of that.
They just have to take it.
And that's hard.
So the,
I think I forgot what the hell the
question was here.
I'm getting tired so I'm losing my
ability to go back where you may get it
wrong when you're interacting with the
audience.
Yes.
Look
what Hitler did was this far as I can
tell,
and I've talked to politicians whose,
who've built grassroots political
parties about how they did it too.
So the audience talks to you when you,
when you deliver,
when you,
when you speak publicly and they talk to
their emotional reactions,
and then you can learn how to say what
produces a given emotional reaction,
especially if that's what you want.
If you want,
say,
control over the crowd or maybe you
want,
you want to harness the anger of the
crowd,
let's say,
because your own motivations.
What were Hitler's motivations?
Here's the psychoanalytic answer.
If you cannot understand the
motivations,
look at the consequences and infer the
motivation.
What's the consequence?
Hitler blows his brains out in a bunker
under Berlin when Europe is info on
fire.
What was the motivation as suicidal
apocalypse?
That's the motivation.
How do you generate a suicidal
apocalypse?
You aim at it.
How do you get the crowd to go along?
You speak in that manner and you watch
for the emotional response and when you
get the anger that you're after,
you facilitate it and you let your
imagination dwell on that and you become
a master of that and that's what Hitler
did and it wasn't like the Germans
weren't angry and they had their
reasons.
World War One was brutal.
They lost the Versailles treaty,
was a catastrophe in the 19 twenties.
Every decent hardworking German lost all
of their savings in hyperinflation and
the entire country was threatened by a
radical leftist revolution.
It was rough and people were not happy
and many of them had been terribly
brutalized by world war one,
so there was no shortage of anger to
capitalize on and Hitler was just the
guy annoyed as he was,
for example,
that he was rejected from art school
three times despite despite having a
fair bit of artistic talent.
He had his reasons for resentment and
anger and hatred,
and that's just a tiny part of it.
Yes,
these things can go terribly wrong.
It depends,
at least in part on what you're aiming
at.
People ask me what I'm aiming at and I
would say,
I mean,
who knows,
right?
Because you don't know yourself and I
don't know myself not to the final
depths,
but I think what I'm aiming out,
I'm hoping is exactly what I say.
I'm aiming out.
I hope that what I'm aiming at is to
tell people stories
and provide them with clinical
intervention in information that's
derived from the best literature and
science that I know so that they can be
fortified in their ability to contend
with tragedy and malevolence and the
reason that I'm doing that as far as I'm
concerned is because when I wrote my
first book,
which was maps of meaning,
the audio version of which is out next
week.
By the way,
I think it'll be easier to understand
because it's red and the intonation is
all there.
I concluded after studying the
psychological dynamics of the Cold War,
that the only proper medication to
tyrannical collectivism was the
sovereignty of the individual and that
as a consequence,
the sovereign individual needed to be
strengthened.
That that was the path forward was least
harm and most potential.
Good.
And I think that's what I'm doing my
evidence for that is that I've been
doing it for 30 years.
I taught courses based on that at
Harvard and at the University of Toronto
consistently.
The lectures were made into a television
program in Toronto that was popular.
The lectures became explosively popular
online.
Everybody can see what I'm saying as far
as I can tell and apart from the hip
pieces,
which are perhaps valid criticisms,
although I don't believe so,
um,
the overwhelming evidence as far as I
can tell is that it's having a positive
consequence.
So when I'm hoping,
and I have people watching me and
criticizing me,
like friends of mine and my family
trying to make sure that this all works.
And so hopefully I'm not doing something
that isn't good.
We'll see.
But yes.
Um,
thank you.
The last,
last question,
what did you think of the last star wars
movie?
I've gone,
I don't know if I saw the last star wars
movie,
but I saw one of the last.
I've probably seen three of the last
five star wars movies I would say.
And I thought they were all the same
movie as the First Star Wars movie.
So,
um,
so I haven't,
they haven't been my cup of tea,
let's say.
Having said that,
it's obvious that,
you know,
the superhero movies,
the star wars movies,
the star trek movies,
the fantastic success that marvel in
particular has had their Superhero
Pantheon.
Like those are the most expensive
artifacts that people make those movies.
That's something to really think about.
You know,
people put $200,000,000
into a movie like that.
It's not the most expensive thing we
make,
but it's bloody well up there,
I can tell you.
And it's pretty interesting to realize
as well that making the special effects
for those movies which,
which is a form of artificial reality,
let's say,
is part of what's driving computational
sophistication forward because the big
processors are being used most
intensively to render reality.
And so whatever's happening in those
movies is something far more significant
than you might think.
I think it all speaks to the
unquenchable power of mythology and its
proclivity to manifest itself in a
multitude of forms and,
and,
and to be eternally compelling to people
and so generally that seems to be a
really good thing to me.
So I mean the Harry Potter series I
think is a better example than the star
wars series because I think that I think
that the star wars series is a bit too
consciously contrived.
Whereas the Harry Potter series is
genuinely,
to my way of thinking anyways,
is a genuine intuitive production and
rolling got her mythology.
She so good at that.
I just can't believe it.
It's just absolutely unbelievable.
And you think of the consequences of
that.
She wrote seven books about wizards like
teenage wizards and child wizards and
magical castle Trenton by giant snakes
and portrayed the battle between good
and evil on a landscape of chaos and
order and you know,
sold.
I don't know what's her empire worth in
terms of total financial consequences?
It would be.
It's in the tens of billions of dollars.
Certainly.
She got all these kids to read 600 page
books.
They produced all these movies that were
fantastically expensive.
Everybody read them and went and watched
them.
It's like,
and what do you see there?
It's a dying and resurrecting hero
fights is satanic,
figure and attains final victory through
death and resurrection.
So like,
you know,
and it wasn't contrived that came out of
the story.
And so the mythologies seeps in no
matter what.
And it's,
I think,
and this is something I learned from
you,
is that it's time for us to understand
it.
We can't just live by it unconsciously
anymore.
We have to understand that as well as
living by it.
And that's the task of the 21st century.
That's what it looks like to me.
So if we understand it,
then maybe we can fortify ourself
against collectivist ideology,
for example.
I'm hoping because that's a bad pathway.
So you were able to turn that question
into very good final words somehow.
Good.
So thank you.
Thank you very much.
You.